this podcast episode is brought to you
by helix sleep
sleep is super important to me in the
last few years i've come to conclude it
is the end-all be-all
that all good things good mood good
performance good everything
seem to stem from good sleep so i've
tried a lot
to optimize and i've tried pills and
potions
all sorts of different mattresses you
name it and for the last few years i've
been sleeping on a helix
midnight luxe mattress i also have one
in the guest bedroom
and feedback from friends has always
been fantastic it's something that they
comment on
helix sleep has a quiz takes about two
minutes to complete that matches your
body type and sleep preferences to the
perfect mattress for you
with helix there's a specific mattress
for each and every
body that is your body also your taste
so let's say you sleep on your side
and like a super soft bed no problem or
if you're a back sleeper who likes a
mattress
that's as firm as a rock they've got a
mattress for you too helix was selected
as the
number one best overall mattress pick of
2020 by gq magazine
wired apartment therapy and many others
just go to helixsleep.com
tim take their two minute sleep quiz and
they'll match you to a customized
mattress that will give you the best
sleep of your life they have a 10 year
warranty and you get to try it out for
100 nights risk free they'll even pick
it up from you if you don't love it and
now my dear listeners helix is offering
up to 200
off of all mattress orders and two free
pillows
at helixsleep.com tim these are not
cheap pillows either so getting two for
free
is an upgraded deal so that's up to 200
off
and two free pillows at helixsleep.com
tim that's helix h-e-l-i-x
sleep.com tim for up to 200
off so check it out one more time helix
h-e-l-i-x sleep dot com slash
tim
this episode is brought to you by
theragun i have
two theraguns and they are worth their
weight in gold i've been using them
every single day whether you're an elite
athlete or just a regular person trying
to get through your day
muscle pain and muscle tension are real
things that's why i use
the theragun i use it at night i use it
after workouts
it is a handheld percussive therapy
device that releases your deepest
muscle tension so for instance at night
i might use it on the bottom of my feet
it's helped with my plantar fasciitis
i will have my girlfriend use it up and
down
the middle of my back and i'll use it on
her it's an easy way for us to actually
trade massages in effect and you can
think of it
in fact as massage reinvented on some
level helps with performance
helps with recovery helps with just
getting your back
to feel better before bed after you've
been sitting for way too many hours
i love this thing and the all-new gen 4
theragun
has a proprietary brushless motor that
is surprisingly quiet
it's easy to use and about as quiet as
an electric toothbrush
it's pretty astonishing you really have
to feel the theragun's
signature power amplitude and
effectiveness to believe it
it's one of my favorite gadgets in my
house at this point so
i encourage you to check it out try
theragun that's thera
t-h-e-r-a-g-u-n there's no substitute
for the gen four theragon
with an oled screen that's oled for
those wondering that's
organic light emitting diode screen
personalized theragon app an
incredible combination of quiet and
power so go to theragon.com
tim right now and get your gen 4th air
gun today or you can watch the videos
on the site which show you all sorts of
different ways to use it a lot of runner
friends of mine use them on their it
bands after long runs
there are a million ways to use it and
the gen 4th era guns start at
just 199 dollars i said i have two i
have the prime
and i also have the pro which is like
the super cadillac version my girlfriend
loves the soft attachments
on that so check it out go to
theragon.com
one more time theragun.com tim
at this altitude i can run flat out for
a half mile before my hands start
shaking can i ask you a personal
question now it is
[Music]
hello boys and girls ladies and germs
this is tim ferriss welcome to another
episode of the tim ferriss show
where it is my job to interview
world-class performers from all
different disciplines to tease out the
habits routines
influences life lessons and so on that
you can apply to your own lives
my guest today is andrew huberman that's
h-u-b-e-r-m-a-n-phd you can find him on
twitter and instagram
at huberman lab andrew is a
neuroscientist and tenured professor in
the department of neurobiology at
stanford
university school of medicine he has
made numerous important contributions to
the fields of brain development brain
function and neural plasticity
andrew is a mcknight foundation and pew
foundation fellow
and recipient of the 2017 cogan that's
c-o-g-a-n
award for his discoveries in the study
of vision work from the hubermann
laboratory at stanford medicine
has been consistently published in top
journals including nature
science and cell andrew is the host of
the hubermann lab podcast which he
launched in january of this year the
show aims to help
viewers and listeners improve their
health with science and science-based
tools
new episodes air every monday on youtube
and all podcast
platforms as mentioned you can find him
on instagram and twitter at
hubermann lab you can find him on the
web at hubermannlab.com
andrew many people have been trying to
matchmake for five or six years
and finally here we are welcome to the
show
oh thanks so much for having me here yes
we've crossed paths
near misses for a long time and it's
great to finally sit down and chat
i thought i would start right in your
wheelhouse and use a headline
to introduce the subject of vision
scientific american interviewed you not
long ago and they titled the piece
quote vision and breathing may be the
secrets to surviving
2020 end quote so breathing
i think for a lot of folks might seem
self-evident stop that you have a lot of
problems on your hands
or if you do it incorrectly we can we
can certainly dive into that
later on vision i think will jump out
is perhaps odd to a lot of folks why
vision why is vision perhaps a secret or
a key to surviving 2020 or any
year for that matter yeah so the
vision and our visual system is perhaps
the strongest lever by which we can
shift
our state of mind and body and that
might at first come as a surprise
because we think of vision as this
thing that we have to see colors and
motion and
recognize faces etc but the two little
goodies in the front of our skull
our eyes are actually part of our
central nervous system
so a lot of people don't realize this
but your neural retina the little light
sensing piece of the eyes
in the back of the eye kind of lines it
like a pie crust
or actually two pieces of your brain
that were deliberately
squeezed out during early development so
they're the only two pieces of your
brain that are outside the cranial vault
as we say and those little pieces of
brain
have an enormous impact on the state of
the rest of your brain
so it's fair to say that what you see
and how you view the world
literally has an incredible impact on
your state of mind
respiration breathing also on your state
of mind and body
but the reason is the following our
visual system
is not just for seeing objects shapes
and colors etc
our eyes have two functions so much in
the same way that our ears
are responsible for hearing but also
there's a balance mechanism in there
our eyes are responsible for detecting
shapes and colors etc but
also for telling the rest of the brain
whether or not to be more alert or more
relaxed and the most fundamental way
that our eyes do that
is communicating time of day the
presence or absence of sunlight
to our central circadian clock and then
the central circadian clock which is
really just an aggregation of neurons
communicates to the rest of the brain
and body
whether or not for instance metabolism
should be higher metabolism should be
low whether or not we should feel like
moving or feel like lying down and not
moving at all
but there are a number of ways in which
the visual system works on
fast time scales to adjust our inner
state
and one of the most simple ways that it
does that
is one that normally happens when we're
stressed or relaxed but
we don't recognize it so for instance if
we are very relaxed
our pupils change or the shape of our
lens changes such that
we actually have dilated vision we see
the entire environment we're in
so-called panoramic vision
when we are stressed or we are excited
about something the pupils dilate the
shape of our lens changes literally the
optics of our eye changes
and the information about the outside
world that's delivered to our the rest
of our brain and body changes
the aperture of our experience our
entire experience
shrinks we get so-called soda straw view
of the world we're looking through soda
straws essentially when we are alert or
stressed
and we've experienced this but we don't
normally
notice it happening so much like
breathing
our experience of life whether or not
we're alert or stressed
excited or calm changes our patterns of
breathing we're all accustomed to that
you know our breathing's speeding up
we're holding our breath in anticipation
but as well our inner state drives
changes in our visual system the
aperture of whether or not we see the
big picture
or we have a very contracted view of the
world
but both those things breathing and
vision
also run in reverse meaning if we change
our pattern of breathing we change our
inner state
if our state changes our breathing
changes so it's reciprocal it's
bidirectional
likewise with vision when we are excited
or stressed
the aperture of our visual window
shrinks we get that soda straw view of
the world
when we are relaxed the aperture of our
vision expands
but as well it runs in both directions
if we expand
our view of the world literally force
our our visual field or just
it's very easy actually you can do it no
matter where you are right now if you
just
try and expand your visual field not by
looking around or moving your head or
eyes but by
trying to see yourself in the
environment that you're in so you
literally dilate your view so you could
see the ceiling and the floor and the
walls if you're inside
or if you're outdoors seeing as big an
aperture of your
visual field or your visual environment
as possible
so you're directing your attention to
even though you might remain looking
straight ahead you're just directing
your attention to
as wide a peripheral view horizontally
and vertically as possible is that what
you mean
that's right exactly so essentially if
you keep your head and eyes mostly
stationary you don't have to be you know
rigid about
rock steady but if you look forward and
you expand your field of view so you
kind of relax your eyes
so that you can see as much of your
environment around you as possible to
the point where you can see yourself in
that environment
what you do is you are turning off the
attentional
and believe it or not the stress
mechanisms that drive your internal
state towards stress
this is why when you go to a vista or
you view a horizon it's very
relaxing because you naturally go into
panoramic vision
when you are indoors you're looking at
your phone you're looking at a computer
or a camera or something of that sort
or you're talking to somebody or an
intense conversation you
may not notice it but your entire visual
field shrinks
to a much smaller aperture and that
drives an
increase in alertness in internal state
and we sometimes call that stress if
it's a negative experience
if it's a positive experience we might
call that love or
obsession or fascination but the
important thing to realize is that both
vision
and breathing have a profound
and very rapid effect on our internal
state of mind
and body and it runs in both directions
our internal state that could be
triggered by a text message or hearing
something that somebody says
drives changes in our breathing and our
vision but our breathing and our vision
can also drive changes in our internal
state and so that article in scientific
american
was a discussion about how we can
leverage the visual system
and the respiration the breathing system
in order to take control
over our internal state because it's not
just that 2020 was stressful
it's that our internal state determines
everything it
doesn't just determine if we feel like
we're having a hard time falling asleep
or we're having a hard time focusing for
instance
it also determines how we batch time how
we analyze
where we are in the world in terms of
our lifespan a good example this would
be when we are very stressed
we fine slice time this is why when
people are in a car accident or
something they might report that things
were in
slow motion they're actually your frame
rate increases
whereas when you're very relaxed your
frame rate
slows down and when we are relaxed we
get
so-called perspective we are able to say
well this too shall pass or
i can place the stressful event in a
context so one thing that's
just fundamental to how our nervous
system works is that we are constantly
placing our experience both our
immediate and past
experience as well as our anticipation
of the future into some sort of larger
context
and our visual system literally how we
are viewing the world at that moment
dictates how we create perspective
in terms of states of mind sounds a
little bit abstract but it's actually
it boils right down to optics of the eye
and very concrete things like how you
move your eyes and how you view the
world
this is super fascinating to me because
i've thought a lot about
breathing and how
on one hand breathing is
a function of the autonomous nervous
systems when you're asleep you don't
have to
consciously inhale and exhale but
simultaneously it's this almost api
into your autonomic nervous system
because while you're awake you can
control and direct and modify your
breathing for that directionality
but i've never thought about it from the
from the visual perspective
and just a quick bit of trivia that is
out of left field but nonetheless came
to
me that people might find interesting is
that
the dilation or this hyperdilation of
pupils
is i don't know how much it is
associated with
arousal or sexual arousal but for those
who have ever heard the word
belladonna is a plant the reason it's
called belladonna beautiful
woman in italian is that it used to be
turned into a tincture
and it is a psychotropic and it is also
very dangerous i don't recommend people
consume it but many many
years ago hundreds of years ago women in
certain parts of europe would create a
tincture and put it into their eyes to
hyper dilate
their pupils because it was thought to
be very very attractive
hence beautiful women could you speak to
how one can
think about using their visual
apparatus or stimulating or not
stimulating their eyes their visual
system
for say sleep if one wants to optimize
for sleep what are some considerations
and it could be that
it could be other inputs but i'd just be
curious to know
how this fits into sleep for you
personally
our light viewing behavior has perhaps
the strongest effect on our levels of
alertness and our capacity to fall
asleep and get a good night's sleep
and this is because at the fundamental
layer of our biology
every cell in our body needs information
about time of day
it's no coincidence that we have a
collection of neurons over the roof of
our mouth the so-called suprachiasmatic
nucleus that's our central circadian
clock it informs every cell in our body
about time of day
but it is deep in our brain it has no
access to light
so there are a collection of neurons in
the eye the so-called
melanops and ganglion cells or sometimes
called intrinsically sensitive
photosensitive ganglion cells these are
just neurons in the back of your eye
remembering
of course that the eye is actually part
of the brain that's outside the skull
and those neurons communicate
to the central clock when it's daytime
and when it's night
so the simple behavior that i do believe
everybody should adopt
including many blind people we've talked
about why that is
is to view ideally sunlight
for two to ten minutes every morning
upon waking
so when you get up in the morning you
really want to get
bright light into your eyes because it
does two things
first of all it triggers the timed
release of cortisol
a healthy level of cortisol into your
system which acts as a wake-up signal
and will promote wakefulness and the
ability to focus throughout the day
it also starts a timer for the onset of
melatonin
this sleepyness hormone or the hormone
of darkness as they say
melatonin is inhibited by light so by
viewing light first thing in the day
you set in motion these two timers one
for wakefulness that starts immediately
and one for sleepiness that starts later
the key thing here is that people are
hearing a lot nowadays about avoiding
blue light blue light is so terrible
well it turns out that blue light is
exactly the wavelength of light that
triggers activation of these cells and
that's exactly what you want
early in the day so people generally
will say well
maybe i should just look at my computer
my phone first thing in the day well
it turns out that these cells are very
hard to activate early in the day and
very easy to activate at night
so it's kind of like the biology is
encouraging us if you will
to take on the right behaviors which are
to get outside even if there's cloud
cover there's a lot more light energy a
lot more photons coming through
cloud cover than you're going to get off
your phone
or a computer and early in the day two
to ten minutes outside without
sunglasses
is going to be really beneficial for a
huge range
of biological functions and brain state
i
have made a practice i'm in the middle
of nowhere in the country right now
of of getting up and not necessarily
doing a full workout but just
jumping rope for literally two to five
minutes
two to ten minutes outside facing
the sun where the sun is perfect and
there's certainly an effect i mean i am
moving so there's an effect on cortisol
and as you noted it's like cortisol
gets this ridiculously bad rap across
the board and it's like guys if you
don't have cortisol you're dead
if you like having storing glycogen and
breaking it down into glucose and so on
you
it's important to have some cortisol
there's a tremendous for me
mood elevating effect of this exposure
and i'm just i really have never
familiarized
myself with the mechanism by which that
would be the case
and certainly if it's placebo i'm happy
to just take placebo but
do you have any explanation for why that
exposure can have such a mood elevating
effect
yeah it's definitely not placebo that
morning light exposure is going to also
trigger the activation of dopamine
release you know dopamine being this
essentially feel good neuromodulator the
best way to conceptualize dopamine is
that yes it's part of the reward system
but it's really the molecule of
motivation
and positive anticipation that's really
what it's about
and i should mention that the cortisol
is going to be released
in a pulse once every 24 hours no matter
what
that's coming as we call it's an
intrinsic rhythm but you can time it by
viewing light
and or by getting exercise early in the
day
there are actually data to just kind of
emphasize what happens when you don't do
this
there are really nice data from my
colleague david spiegel's lab he
actually co-published this with the
great
bob sapolsky a few years ago david's our
associate chair of psychiatry at
stanford
and they showed that if that cortisol
pulse
shows up later in the day and especially
if it's around 8 or 9 p.m
then it's associated with depression by
shifting that cortisol pulse earlier in
the day
you ameliorate some of the symptoms of
depression
and because of the dopamine release you
get this overall mood enhancement
there are four things that really time
our circadian biology and these
mood mechanisms properly and align us
for sleep and they
the most powerful time keeper as they
say zeitgeist
germans discovered this mechanism
initially so the most powerful time
keeper
that's there it is i knew you'd do it
better than i would
is is light when you view light and
light is the most powerful stimulus for
your biology and central circadian clock
then it's exercise so it's your protocol
of
jumping rope facing the sun you're
layering on timekeepers you're giving
more
signals to the central clock and the
rest of your body about
when to be active and you're also
indirectly signaling when
you will want to be asleep later then
it's feeding i know a lot of people fast
through the early part of the day now
that's very fashionable and i do that as
well but were you to
eat early in the day that can also help
and then the other one is social cues
so interacting with people early in the
day or with your dog
early in the day i have a dog live alone
with my dog so
that's how i interact with the world
socially but those things are going to
create wake up signals and your body
will start to anticipate them and your
brain will start to anticipate them
such that if you miss it for a day
you're still going to wake up and feel
that alertness signal
early in the day so this is not
something that you have to do every day
but ideally you do it every day because
it's like
setting a clock or a watch properly and
i should mention that for people that
live in areas with very dense cloud
cover
you can use light boxes and things of
that sort but
irrespective of that in the morning and
during the day and anytime you want to
be alert you want to flip on as many
overhead lights as possible
this is because these cells in the eye
that trigger activation and alertness of
the rest of the brain and nervous system
reside in the lower portion of the eye
they view the upper visual field
now the inverse of all this is also
important
as you approach the evening or night
time and you want to go to sleep
that is a time to start avoiding bright
lights of any color
not just blue light and if possible to
place
whatever lights are present in your
environment lower in your visual field
so this would be desk lamps
most people don't have floor lighting
dim the lights
if you want to wear blue blockers or do
something of that sort that's fine but i
think people have taken the blue blocker
thing a little too far by wearing them
all day that's actually going to disrupt
your circadian clocks
so in the evening you really want to
avoid
bright light of any kind and again it's
an averaging if you do this every once
in a while you go to the bathroom middle
of the night or you have an emergency
and things
are really bright for one night it's not
going to screw you up however there was
a paper published in the journal cell
a few years ago by my good friend and
colleague at the national institutes of
mental health his name is sammer hattar
he's the head of the chronobiology unit
at the national institutes of mental
health
and what sammer's lab showed
is that bright light exposure of any
wavelength between the hours
of about 11 pm and 4 am
caused a serious disruption in the
dopamine system
such that in subsequent days you have
a disruption in a lowering of mood
difficulty in learning
there's a cascade of things that happen
in other words we get
punished for light viewing at the wrong
times of the circadian cycle and we get
rewarded for light viewing at the
correct times of the circadian cycle
let's talk about the latter portion of
the day
before i get to that though just for my
understanding if one say wants to target
going to bed
or more accurately feeling sleepy enough
to go to bed easily
with rapid onset at say 10 pm
is there a preferred time to get that
exposure
early in the day in the sense that if
i'm doing my 10 minutes of jumping rope
facing the sun
is it best to have it a certain
distance temporarily from when i want to
go to sleep
yes it's about 14 to 16 hours prior to
when you want to sleep is the ideal time
to get that morning light exposure and
if we want to get a little bit technical
about this
we can and i'll do my best to make it
clear because there's also a way that
you can
use this mechanism to shift your
circadian clock to avoid jet lag and
shift work
i'll just ask you so what's your typical
wake up time
not getting up in the middle that i'm
using the restroom necessarily and then
going back to sleep but when do you
finally get
get up and get out of bed what what time
does is that typically
i would say when i'm living my best life
and not
not being marty from back to the future
it's
usually seven o'clock let's just say
okay so if seven o'clock is your average
wake-up time then we can
be pretty sure that two hours prior to
your natural wake-up time
is what's called your temperature
minimum it's when your body temperature
was
lowest that temperature minimum and i
should be clear we don't need to know
your actual temperature no one needs to
know their actual temperature minimum
but you can count on
the fact that two hours before waking up
your body temperature
is close to or at its lowest point and
to be clear
this would be if you are waking without
an alarm clock
right that would be if you're following
natural rhythms correct
so if you view light i should mention
that you have to do this light viewing
behavior with your eyes
that might seem obvious but some years
ago there was a paper published in
the journal science which is one of the
three apex journals science nature cell
and it stated that light presented to
the back of the knee
of humans could shift their circadian
clocks and
that paper was retracted by the same
authors that published the study
there was a technical flaw humans have
no
extraocular photoreception so we
need to tell those cells of the body
what time of day it is essentially where
we are in time
by light viewing behavior with the eyes
blind people do this a little bit
differently
some blind people actually still retain
these so-called melanopsin cells
people without eyes at all maybe for a
burn victim or something they
they are going to use social cues and
exercise and other things but
most everybody on the planet does this
through light viewing behavior
so when i say get light what i mean is
get light in your eyes
obviously never so bright that it's
going to damage your eyes you'll know if
a light's too bright
because you'll want to close your
eyelids that's a simple rule of thumb
but the key thing here is that
if you view light in particular bright
light
in the hour or two before that
temperature minimum so for you tim that
would be
between you know around 3 a.m or 4 a.m
it's going to have the quality of
delaying your circadian clock what it'll
effectively do
is make you want to stay awake later and
it will make you
want to sleep in later the following
nights
however if you view light in the hour or
so
immediately after that so-called
temperature minimum so this for you this
would be
6am or 7am it's going to
shift your clock in the other direction
you're going to want to go to bed a
little bit earlier
and you're going to want to wake up a
little bit earlier the next night
now if you hear this you're probably
thinking well
my clock is always more or less in the
same place how come it doesn't jump
around i wake up i view light how come
i'm not going to bed earlier and earlier
every night and waking up earlier and
earlier
the reason is there's a second time of
day which is in the evening as the sun
sets
where your circadian clock is also
vulnerable again to these shifts and
typically
because most of us are viewing light in
the late afternoon
all of us are naturally having our clock
shifted so that we want to get up
earlier and go to bed earlier the next
night
and morning but we're also delaying our
clock a little bit in the afternoon
now we can make this all very simple the
simple thing to do is
within 30 minutes of waking up get
bright light exposure in your eyes
and not from a phone or from a screen
because it won't be sufficiently bright
get it from sunlight and if you can't
get it from sunlight
you can use one of these light pads i
don't use one of these expensive wake
clocks or something like that i bought
an led drawing pad
it's like a trace table like the artist
cheat mechanism
it actually says on it i forget the
company but it says 930 lux you can find
these very inexpensively online
and that's going to work great i just
set it at my desk in the morning if it's
very overcast and i'll work
now it is important to get outside
because
even though your windows or the
windshield of your car
is optically clear it filters out a lot
of that blue light that's important for
setting your circadian clock
so two to ten minutes of light viewing
early in the day and then
you can do yourself a great favor as
well by
going outside in the evening or late
afternoon as the sun is approaching this
what we call low solar angle
because that will also send another
signal
to the brain that it's evening
so there's a morning stimulus and an
evening stimulus
this only takes a few minutes each day
and what's
key to understand is that the cells in
the of your body they're going to have
all these rhythms of liver function and
metabolic function your brain is going
to have its rhythms of alertness and
anxiety and sleepiness providing
multiple signals so for you exercise and
light in the morning
and then in the afternoon a little bit
of light is going to tell your system
in a redundant way but in a powerful way
these are the times to be awake these
are the times to be asleep and then if
you like we can talk about evening
behavior but that temperature minimum
is worth knowing because if ever you are
traveling for instance to europe
what you can do is in the two or three
days before
you can just set your alarm wake up
around your temperature minimum
maybe an hour before turn on some bright
lights in your
home so you get bright light exposure
and you will start to shift your clock
forward that nine hour jump can be
accomplished in about two days if you do
this correctly
and the reverse is also true you could
shift your clock earlier if you like
and when you land in europe if we want
to get down into the weeds
when you land in europe you have to be
cognizant of
what your clock is back home remember
your temperature minimum it's much more
important than where you are in your new
environment that temperature minimum is
an anchor point remember
light viewed in the hour or two before
that temperature minimum will make you
want to go to sleep later
and wake up later light viewed after
that temperature minimum
will make you want to go to sleep
earlier and wake up earlier
let's talk about something that
is a perennial topic and that is sleep
aids specifically i'd love to get your
opinion on
various supplements or prescription
medications for that matter that people
might
use there's a huge list of things that
people
could use on the prescription side
certainly you've got the ambience and
the tracidones and so on
then on the supplemental side you've got
melatonin
very very popular you have
california poppy i mean there's an
infinitely long list of various
supplements
i would love to hear your thoughts on at
least two of these
one is melatonin because of its
popularity
and then the second is actually
phosphatidylserine
so ps for short and using it to
blunt cortisol release
after going to bed now just be curious
to know if you have any opinions
on those or any others that you would
advise against or
advocate for or use personally
sure so i'll say why i'm not a fan of
melatonin
when i was a graduate student i worked
on the melatonin system in the circadian
system
and one of the most powerful effects of
melatonin is to suppress
puberty the melatonin system is closely
linked up with gaba inhibitory
neurons in the hypothalamus it
effectively keeps puberty from happening
so
the melatonin rhythms of young children
pre-pubertal children
are not as phasic right they're pretty
constant
and that's one of the reasons they don't
go into puberty there are many other
reasons they don't go into puberty until
certain triggers
are set but melatonin has strong effects
on the sex steroid hormones the pathways
related to estrogen and testosterone
and i think it was the one experiment
that i did where we took
we were working on these little uh
they're called siberian hamsters these
little hamsters who
in long days because they are seasonally
breeding
animals in long days these siberian
hamsters
have testicles well that at least for
siberian hamsters are a pretty
impressive size
if however you inject those animals with
melatonin or you put them into short
days so you increase the amount of
darkness and you decrease the amount of
light remembering of course that light
inhibits melatonin
their testicles shrink to the size of a
grain of rice
so i don't know if this was my male ego
or something but
i saw that experiment and i thought wow
this is powerful stuff this melatonin
stuff
and it turns out in females of the same
species
they leave estrus they stop cycling they
don't have menstrual cycles they have
estrous cycles
and there are powerful effects of
melatonin on the reproductive axis now
humans are not seasonal breeders and
we have a more robust sex steroid
hormone axis than that
but especially for children but also for
adults it just seems to me that
melatonin has a number of other effects
that are
worth considering enough effects that i
tend to avoid it
now i should also say that most of the
concentrations of melatonin that are in
supplements
are 10 to 1 000 times what the
endogenous
internal levels would naturally be so
people taking melatonin are
seeing dramatic effects but you're
taking super physiological levels of
melatonin we all kind of balk when we
hear about
people taking you know a thousand
milligrams of testosterone
cypionate a week which unfortunately
certain people do
but this is the equivalent of
super dosing sleep hormones and
these are hormones that have other
issues and other roles i should say in
the body
so that's why i veer away from melatonin
also there are three things that i
personally have found
to be much more beneficial that
seem to have very good safety margins of
course everyone needs to check with
their physician
but those three things are magnesium 3
and 8
t-h-r-e-o-n-a-t-e or by glycinate
magnesium by glycine magnesium 3-8 and
magnesium by glycinate
are able to be transported across the
blood-brain barrier more readily than
other forms of magnesium
i know you know a lot about this topic
tim so correct me anywhere i might
misspeak but like for instance magnesium
citrate is a great laxative
it goes by another name too you can
imagine what it might be that will
remind you that it's a it's a great
laxative but it's not
great at inducing sleep magnesium 3 and
8 or magnesium by glycinate so 200 to
400 milligrams
about 30 minutes before sleep is a
powerful sleep aid
people with heart issues might not want
to take it or might want to check with
their doctor
but i take a cocktail of magnesium three
and eight and then two other things one
is very commonly known which is theanine
t-h-e-a-n-i-n-e
200-400 milligrams of theanine can
create a kind of a hypnotic state help
you
fall asleep basically falling asleep
requires turning off your thoughts
and the only people that should really
avoid theanine
i think are people who suffer from
sleepwalking or night terrors
it can create very vivid dreams and then
the third thing
is apogenin a-p-i-g-e-n-i-n
which is a derivative of chamomile but
it acts as a chloride channel
agonist so it essentially helps shut
down the forebrain by
hyperpolarizing neurons and all this
kind of stuff for the aficionados if
they want to know so that cocktail of 50
milligrams of apogenin
300 to 400 milligrams of magnesium 3 and
8 or by glycinate
and 200 to 400 milligrams of theanine
for me has been the best way to
consistently fall asleep quickly
and stay asleep most if not the entire
night which for me is about seven
eight hours and of course i'm not a
physician i'm a scientist everyone needs
to figure out what's right for them
but many many people who i've
recommended this to have told me
that in combination with the morning
light viewing
that their sleep has been completely
transformed they thought they were
so-called insomniacs
but they actually were just having a
hard time turning off their thoughts and
probably their cortisol was drifting too
late in the day
so to that cortisol point this is
fascinating and i just
find it endlessly interesting
that different forms of magnesium
can be so target-specific with respect
to different tissues in the body
so so fascinating with respect to
cortisol
and needless to say i i have used
phosphatidylserine before sleep to help
blunt cortisol release but i do
cycle i use it as needed really if
there's a lot of rumination or i've had
a particularly stressful day
but do you have any thoughts on
whether or not you would ever do that
personally or if you'd be too concerned
about
side effects or long-term side effects i
suppose that could be
a larger issue if you're just never
cycling off but do you have any thoughts
on using
different compounds to blunt cortisol
release if you're over ruminating
and want to sort of minimize that in
this case stress response
while you're trying to sleep i have not
tried ps
i use ashwagandha from time to time if
i'm in a particularly long
bout of stress one of the things that i
think is irrelevant here is that we hear
about stress but
as terrible but of course short-term
stress buffers the immune system it
actually activates the spleen to release
killer cells and things of that sort
we are more robust in fighting off
infection in the short term
from pulses and cortisol but i would say
we can define
long term stress as if you are having
sleep disruption
or you're feeling you're like you're in
that wired and tired
mode we don't really have a technical
name for this
for more than two or three days you're
starting to enter the realm of long-term
stress and that's where buffering
cortisol can really help and that's
where i start to take some ashwagandha
late in the day
there's good evidence it can buffer
cortisol i do cycle it so i'm not going
to take it
every night or every day i would
probably stop after a week or so
and then just go back to my normal
regimen which doesn't include
ashwagandha but i always have some on
hand
i have to say that i certainly use and
enjoy the benefits of supplements
many of them in fact but the practice
that for me
has really helped reduce stress and
allowed me to
fall asleep more easily and control my
state of mind
late in the evening is this practice
that some people call yoga nidra
which literally means yoga sleep and
that practice
of taking 20 or 30 minutes a day
and it doesn't have to be done every day
and lying down
and doing a sort of body scan it
involves some long exhale breathing
which is very relaxing to the nervous
system
and really allowing the mind to enter
one of these pseudo-sleep states
we know from work in my laboratory and
work that i'm doing with david spiegel's
laboratory as well as work from other
labs
that that state of shallow nap or
shallow sleep done
in waking allows the brain to
and the person to get better at turning
off their thoughts and falling asleep in
the evening
so i use both behavioral tools and
pharmacology which of course is really
what supplementation is
i don't have any problem with buffering
cortisol
a little bit in the short term so doing
that for a week or two but i
wouldn't suggest that people suppress
their cortisol
long term unless there's a real clinical
need to do that
long term being longer than two weeks
just a quick thanks to one of our
sponsors and we'll be right back to the
show
this episode is brought to you by
athletic greens i get asked
all the time what i would take if i
could only take one supplement
the answer is invariably athletic greens
i view it as all-in-one nutritional
insurance
i recommended it in fact in the four
hour body this is more than ten years
ago
and i did not get paid to do so with
approximately 75 vitamins
minerals and whole foods sourced
ingredients you'd be very hard-pressed
to find a more nutrient-dense and
comprehensive formula
on the market it has multivitamins
multi-mineral greens complex
probiotics and prebiotics for gut health
and immunity formula digestive enzymes
adaptogens and much more i usually take
it once or twice a day just to make sure
i've covered my bases if i miss anything
i'm not aware of
of course i focus on nutrient-dense
meals to begin with that's the basis
but athletic greens makes it easy to get
a lot of nutrition when whole foods
aren't readily available
from travel packets i always have them
in my bag
when i'm zipping around right now
athletic greens is giving my audience a
special
offer on top of their all-in-one formula
which is a free
vitamin d supplement and five free
travel packs with your first
subscription purchase many of us are
deficient in vitamin d
i found that true for myself which is
usually produced in our bodies from sun
exposure so
adding a vitamin d supplement to your
daily routine is a great option for
additional immune support
support your immunity gut health and
energy by visiting
athleticgreens.com tim you'll receive up
to a year's supply
of vitamin d and 5 free travel packs
with your subscription
again that's athleticgreens.com
you mentioned long exhales in the
context of the yoga nidra practice
is it fair to refer to that yoga nidra
practice is
also non-sleep deep rest or nsdr are
those separate
phenomena yeah so yoga nidra is
one of several what we call nsdr
non-sleep deep rest protocols
admittedly i coined the term nsdr
because scientists like acronyms
almost as much as the military likes
acronyms and i did it
deliberately not to rob the
beautiful history and community that is
yoga nidra and the yogic communities of
anything
but rather because many people are
averse to doing anything
that has a name like yoga nidra and yet
it's such a powerful tool it's a
zero-cost tool that has
enormous effects on not just accessing
sleep and calm but
enhancing rates of neuroplasticity
something that we could talk more about
also david spiegel again our associate
chair of psychiatry at stanford a close
collaborator and friend of mine
is a world expert in clinical hypnosis
we are part of a
just in in full disclosure we both sit
on the advisory board of a company
called reverie
r-e-v-e-r-i dot com reverie is a
zero cost app beyond android and apple
that has short hypnosis protocols
anywhere from
10 minutes to 15 minutes hypnosis
and yoga nidra both fall under the
umbrella of nsdr non-sleep depressed and
these are protocols that
people can use to deliberately access
states of deep rest for sake of
again falling asleep more easily
reducing stress but also
for enhancing rates of learning of
neuroplasticity and
because these are zero cost tools i and
because they're grounded in excellent
peer-reviewed research
i feel comfortable mentioning them and
what you find
is that if people who are not familiar
with
meditation or mindfulness or maybe
they're not from west l.a or the bay
area
um if they hear yoganidra they think
magic carpets and they think
and they hear hypnosis and they think
that somebody's going to control their
brain nsdr is my attempt
to create a more friendly language which
is because
all of these things are really just the
same thing they really involve two
things
one self-directing a state of calm
that's something that we never
learn how to do unless we have a need to
do it we suffer some trauma we have
chronic stress
we start taking a mindfulness class we
self-inducing a state of calm through
respiration and vision
is the hallmark of yoganidra and
hypnosis and frankly
of all meditative practices our thoughts
follow
our vision and breathing and i can
explain why that is in a moment
in addition these nsdr type practices
involve not just self-directing calm but
they also involve directing our focus
to something we generally have a hard
time falling asleep because we think we
have to turn off our thoughts completely
like a switch
but the transition to sleep involves
allowing our thoughts to become
fragmented and then we become relaxed
and then the brain enters the state
where space and time are very fluid
and not under our conscious control and
those are things that we can teach
ourselves
so yoga ninja scripts are found all over
youtube there's some great apps out
there
the zero cost ones that i use are any of
the
stuff by comedy k-a-m-i-n-i desai
d-e-s-a-i i like her voice very much
some people like my sister loves
liam gillen's voice another zero cost
yoga nidra tool
liam gillen double l-g-i-l-l-e-n
you have to find a voice that you like
the reverie app is david's voice
he has a very hypnotic voice and there
are scripts in there for
smoking cessation stress and anxiety
sleep etc
these i really want to emphasize in
addition to being zero costs
are very powerful tools if done
regularly
there are two papers that were published
in the last two years from
cell reports and cell press journal
excellent journal showing that
a 20-minute non-sleep deep breath
protocol
after a bout of intense focus or intense
attempt to learn anything skill learning
or cognitive learning
accelerates plasticity by about 50
percent so
you are learning faster much faster and
retention of that information
lasts much longer and that's because
these are sleep-like states and we know
that neuroplasticity the brain's ability
to change in response to experience
is triggered by high focus by deliberate
periods of very high focus
but the actual rewiring of neurons the
formation of new synapses and the
reordering of the circuitry that leads
to that skill or that
cognitive ability becoming reflexive
that happens in states of deep
rest and non-sleep deep breast nsdr
whether it's hypnosis or yoga nedra or a
shallow nap of about 20 30 minutes
those things will all accelerate
learning
let's hop around just a little bit yoga
nidra first on the
nsdr study that you mentioned and the
increase in plasticity which i'm
assuming was measured by
retention recall etc but perhaps it
wasn't if you could send
afterwards a link to that study i'll put
it in the show notes for listeners
who who might be interested we've
touched on breathing
in a few different capacities i have a
term in front of me
that seems kind of self-explanatory but
i don't know
what form it takes physiological size
contrasted with other breathing methods
for stress reduction
could you define what that is
yeah a few years ago when my laboratory
got interested in studying stress in
humans
we asked ourselves what are the patterns
of breathing that
allow for the most rapid reduction in
stress levels
and more importantly what are the
patterns of breathing that can be done
in real time
so that people can adjust their stress
while they're still engaging in life
right breath work classes running off to
sln for a weekend is a magical
experience but
life demands pressing on you that's
typically when you feel stressed so
it is still true that vacation long
meditation retreats and massages
or a nice drink if you're of drinking
age still work but they're slow and they
take you offline
the physiological side is a pattern of
breathing that was actually discovered
by physiologists in the 30s
and that was essentially rediscovered by
professor jack feldman at ucla a world
expert in the neurobiology of
respiration
and by my colleague mark krasnow at
stanford who studies lung function
the physiological side is a pattern of
breathing that we all
engage in in deep sleep when levels of
carbon dioxide in our bloodstream get
too
high we or our dogs you can see your dog
do this we'll do a double inhale
followed by an extended exhale
children or or adults for that matter
that are sobbing
and lose their breath so to speak will
also do a double inhale exhale that's
the spontaneous
execution of what we call the
physiological sigh the reason
it works so well to relax us is because
it offloads a lot of carbon dioxide all
at once
and the way it works is the following
our lungs are not just too big bags of
air
we have all these little millions of
sacks of air that if we were to lay them
out
flat they would be as big as about a
tennis court or so
the volume of air therefore and the
volume of carbon dioxide that we can
offload
is tremendously high except that we get
stressed as carbon dioxide builds up on
our bloodstream
and is kind of a double whammy these
little sacs deflate
now when we do a double inhale so i'll
do this now twice through my nose or you
could do this or
you could do it through your mouth but
it works best for your nose it's inhale
and then you sneak a little bit more air
in at the very end when you do that
you re-inflate those little sacs and
when you
exhale then you discard
all the carbon dioxide at once so the
simple way to describe
this protocol is that unless you are
under water
you do a double inhale followed by an
extended exhale
and you offload the maximum amount of
carbon dioxide and we found in our
laboratory
and other laboratories have found that
just one
two or three of those physiological size
brings your level of stress
down very very fast and it's a tool that
you know you can use
any time i do hope that people will kind
of watch other people
or dogs as they start to relax or go
down to sleep you'll see this pattern of
breathing but again it can be
consciously driven
the other thing about breathing and the
reason why exhales are so vital
is the following i know there's a lot of
interest nowadays in
heart rate variability well
most people don't realize this but your
breathing is actually driving heart rate
variability so when you inhale
this dome shaped muscle beneath your
lungs your diaphragm actually
moves down because the lungs expand it
moves down when you do that
you create more space in the thoracic
cavity
and you actually the heart gets a little
bigger it actually expands
as a consequence blood flows more slowly
through that larger volume
and the brain quickly sends a signal
down to the heart to speed the heart
up the short simple version of this is
inhales
speed the heart up when you exhale
the opposite is true that dome-shaped
muscle the diaphragm moves up
the space in your thoracic cavity gets a
little bit smaller the heart gets a
little bit smaller
blood moves more quickly through that
small volume and the brain sends a
signal to the heart
to slow the heart down physicians know
this as respiratory sinus arrhythmia
but this is the basis of what we call
hrv heart rate variability
and the simple way to remember this is
anytime you emphasize exhales
in other words making them longer than
your inhales
you are slowing the heart rate down
you're calming your system
anytime you emphasize inhales you make
them more vigorous or longer than your
exhales you're speeding up your heart
i'd like to come back to hypnosis for a
second i've never
been hypnotized nor well maybe i have
self-hypnotized and just not realized
that's what i was doing
what characterizes hypnosis or how would
we define that
and do the states induced
by hypnosis have any
shared characteristics with some of the
states induced by
any psychedelics so hypnosis is a state
of calm and high focus
so context is restricted it's like
looking at something through a telephoto
lens
you're eliminating the surround so it's
a state of high focus
which normally as we talked about
earlier with the aperture the visual
system would be associated with a high
degree of
excitement or stress but hypnosis is a
unique state
because you have a high degree of focus
but you're very relaxed
and just to remind people that
neuroplasticity is triggered by
states of high focus followed by periods
of relaxation
later in deep sleep or in non-sleep deep
rest in hypnosis it brings both those
states together
at the same time and this is one of the
reasons it's effective
in accelerating neuroplasticity i could
probably do it right now to see if how
hypnotizable you are there's actually a
test a clinical test called the spiegel
eye roll test
spiegel's father was a hypnotist and a
psychiatrist so these i want to be clear
these are not stage hypnotists these are
board-certified mds and phds
who there's a lot of scientific research
to support what we're about to talk
about so
typically when we get sleepy when we're
relaxed our eyelids close and our eyes
go down and the chin goes down the
induction to hypnosis
involves doing the opposite looking up
which actually believe it or not creates
a state of alertness
and then having you close your eyes so
it creates a
kind of conflict in the cranial nerves
that innervate the eye and eyelid
muscles again the eyes and your state of
mind are so
intricately wired back there in the
brainstem so if you
could look up toward the ceiling tim
with your eyes open
and then just while still maintaining
upward gaze if you could just slowly
close your eyelids
oh boy you're really hypnotizable um
so what did you see that was deeply
uncomfortable
yeah i know it's it's a little bit odd
so so for those of you listening or
watching
you sort of look up towards what you
know sometimes in yoga communities
or meditation communities they call the
third eye center you know we don't
actually have a third eye but if we did
it would probably be
someone decided it would be between our
two eyes on our forehead so by looking
up your inducing alertness
and then you're creating this conflict
where where i asked you to close your
eyelids
which is what you do when you're in a
state of sleepiness
and what spiegel both spiegel senior and
spiegel jr have figured out
is that it's a very good predictor of
how hypnotizable people
are you can look up the spiegel eye rule
test and what i was looking for
is let's say if somebody is not very
hypnotizable
what will happen is as they close their
eyes they'll have a hard time closing
them slowly they'll just kind of snap
shut and their eyes will roll forward in
other words i'll see their pupils again
what happened when i saw you
do this is that your eyelids were
closing very slowly and i saw the whites
of your eyes your eyes were starting to
roll back into your head
so you would have a score of probably
about a four which is very hypnotizable
i'm about a four some people you'll just
notice you say look up and then slowly
close your eyes and their eyes will just
kind of snap shut in their eyes will
roll forward right before it snaps shut
so you can do this experiment of sorts
on people that you know
and it predicts pretty well how quickly
or easily you you will go into hypnosis
i should mention that no one will go
into hypnosis if they don't want to
but if you're interested in exploring
hypnosis with the reverie app or with a
clinical hypnotist
and your eyes roll back the way that
yours did tim then um
you're home free you're you're going to
be long amazing oh amazing i could uh
maybe i'll
start speaking in tongues too it does
have a good good associated look with it
how would you explain the utility of
hypnosis
and and then i do want to hear if there
are any
sort of correlates to some of the
known effects of psychedelics and that's
a wide spectrum
of class so we could choose we could
choose
a given compound but what are the what
are the clinical applications because in
my
hypnosis naive mind i think
smoking cessation isn't it good for
quitting smoking isn't it good for
really just these anecdotal reports that
i've read at one point or another but
what's the clinical what are some of the
clinical applications
or practical applications of hypnosis
yeah so for smoking cessation if people
do the practice
about a sixty to eighty percent success
rate depending on the study you look at
these were all blinded controlled
studies in terms of anxiety relief
those are tremendously strong effects as
many as 90 percent of people are going
to feel
significant improvement in anxiety for
pain management
for chronic pain there's a high degree
of success so
you know people will vary depending on
how hypnotizable they are and how
regular they are about the practice
but anywhere from a 50 to 75 percent of
people will experience a significant
reduction in chronic pain
and if they are using pain meds they
tend to be able to take lower doses
of pain medications in order to manage
that pain
so it's quite powerful now for trauma
and things of that sort it it needs to
be done with a
clinical i would hope board certified md
clinical
hypnotist and very the success rates are
quite high as well
and if you want more research about this
inside the reverie app there's a long
list of resources you could also
i can send over a good review article
that david's written
in these are again published in very
fine
quality peer-reviewed journals of the
new england journal jama
sort and things like that great in terms
of
similarity to psychedelics they are
quite distinct actually
so hypnosis being a state of high degree
of focus and relaxation
is a bit similar to some of the
so-called psychedelics so mdma assisted
psychotherapy
which it appears thanks to the support
and work of people like you and the maps
group and the group at hopkins in
particular matthew johnson and i realize
there are other people in that mix but
it's
it i have to just say as a as a point
it's it's really exciting to see what's
happening
and the enthusiasm about safe building
safe protocols that people can access
after so many years of people having to
do this kind of renegade
or in unregulated environments mdma
creates in a very atypical state
it's a state of high dopamine release
now typically dopamine is associated
with
a focus on things external to us
dopamine being a molecule associated
with motivation and reward makes us want
to do
more of things that brought the dopamine
whether or not that's food sex online
viewing of any kind etc it's not always
uh
it's not always bad but online viewing
online viewing whatever that is the best
way to describe the effects of dopamine
are that there's a book actually quite
good book called the molecule of more
and that's a great way to describe it i
wish i had written that book i read the
book and thought i wish i had written
this book it's
because i i love the neuromodulator
systems and it is the molecule of more
and actually
anyone that thinks that dopamine is
about pleasure not motivation
or seeking more consider this this is an
anecdote i borrowed from
my colleague anna lemke who's in the
department of psychiatry
at stanford the next time you eat a
piece of chocolate
or you engage in a behavior that feels
particularly
delicious notice the sensation and the
thoughts in your mind
it's rarely about complete presence and
desire
for staying present it's usually a
desire
for more it's this i want more of this
please as opposed to really basking in
the experience
and i should mention that anna has a
wonderful book coming out in august
called dopamine nation she was in the
social dilemma she's an addiction
therapist and
psychiatrist and talks a lot about the
dopamine system so dopamine makes us
want
more of whatever feels really good and
that tends to place us in an external
focus
serotonin another feel-good molecule is
exact
opposite it tends to make us feel good
with what we already have
it tends to be the incredible feelings
of of
warmth that you know holding a child or
a loved one
or time with your dog i have this
bulldog costello and
there's times when i just sit with him
and i feel immense pleasure
just being there i don't think i want
four bulldogs in fact i definitely don't
want four bulldogs
the snoring is loud enough already but
it's about experiencing the here and now
in a full and complete way mdma is
unique because
it creates huge increases in dopamine
and serotonin at the same time
and we don't ordinarily see that in
natural experience
and it has this unique property of
making people feel
very excited and positive about
their relationship to their internal
state and so it has a kind of looping
back of a mechanism that normally would
place us
in the viewing of the exterior what's
out there what can i get more of who can
i interact with more of what
drug can i take more of that's going to
make me feel this way so mdma is very
unique
and i mention it because it has certain
correlates with hypnosis in that it's a
very focused
state in fact so much so that let's just
say
i could imagine that if you're hearing
music and you focus on that music you
can
really kind of start to merge with the
music whereas if you focus on your
internal state you can merge with your
internal state
and that's why i do think it's important
that some of that if people are doing it
in a clinical setting
be guided because otherwise the
experience can be sort of lost on
whatever is external
other psychedelics of the sort like
psilocybin lsd
they have a very sleep-like state they
tend to be more serotonergic in nature
and they are very similar to sleep in
the sense that space and time become
very fluid
whatever top-down governing mechanisms
exist in the brain so-called
you know executive function some of that
seems to be disregulated enough
so that inside of those psychedelic
states
and in certainly inside of dreams
anything can really happen and you can
essentially see and appreciate novel
associations that normally wouldn't
occur in waking
states we should remember that the two
extremes of human experience
are stress and or excitement so highly
contracted visual window
highly contracted time domain everything
sliced very finely what's happening next
what's going to happen next think you're
in the line at the airport and the
person in front of you is moving slowly
and you got a plane to catch
everything constricted to right there
both in space and time
and then sleep where in sleep space and
time are extremely fluid
anything can happen and you are
essentially
out of control mentally it's just
whatever is going to happen can happen
psychedelics
are very much like that except that in
lsd and psilocybin assisted states
you're alert
so i would say that psilocybin and
lsd-like states are similar to hypnosis
in that way
but hypnosis has a little bit more of a
rigidity to it it's set
toward a particular focus like let's
work on your control over stress
or smoking or pain and so i would say
the three of them
occupy neighboring spaces but none of
them overlap completely
yeah i'd be so curious to see some type
of multimodal
study and perhaps they've been done by
just looking at pharmacological
interventions combined with
hypnosis right so if we made hypnosis
the the default sort of control state
and then you had an arm
that was comparing hypnosis plus
fill in the blank not necessarily
psychedelics certainly i mean you could
it could be an intact degenerate and
pathogen like
mdma it could be tryptamine like
psilocybin or it could be like a
phenethylamine like mescaline
which has very different effects
certainly i think you know michael
pollan does a good job of describing
this
in his new book your mind on plants his
entire section discussing the
mescaline experience which is really in
a sense an
amplification of the real in
high resolution certainly dose dependent
versus
transportation a allah the tryptamines
like lsd or soul 7 that'll be very very
interesting to see
it would i and i have to say you know as
usual you're you're
five years or more ahead of everybody
else tim and i don't say that for
sake of flattery i mean you have a you
have a way of spotting the horizon and i
think
we are so caught up as a culture now in
asking
what should we do what should we take
what device should i use i would say
you've got behavioral tools
we all have to eat sooner or later
nutrition supplementation prescription
drugs
off-label and on label and then you got
brain machine interface devices
for reading and writing to the nervous
system and body for measuring things and
changing things
and we always think of those as separate
bins but
as you're pointing out i think the most
interesting bin is to consider
well maybe at some point a learning bout
is going to be
300 milligrams of alpha gpc and a
particular breathing protocol that will
have a synergistic effect
i think that's where the real immediate
future of beneficial brain change
lies and i think even the folks at
neural link you know a guy that came up
through my lab he's a neurosurgeon matt
mcdougall
is at neurolink now and they have other
excellent neuroscientists there and
you can be sure that they're thinking
clinical issues first
and they're thinking obviously brain
machine interface and chips and robotics
and things of that sort
but you can bet just given who makes up
that company
of roster that they're probably also
thinking about ways to accelerate
plasticity using a combination of brain
machine interface
and pharmacology and if they're not
thinking about that they definitely
should
so i think for the typical person who's
not gonna plant a chip beneath their
skull
i think you're hitting the nail on the
head which is that we need to think
about
what works independently and combining
those for sake of synergy
that's what's going to get us where we
need to go much faster
i also think just to build on what you
said and thanks for the kind words
that when you look at these possible
synergistic combinations
you could also end up and then this is
not a certainty but it's a possibility
having a much more appealing risk
benefit calculus in the sense that if
you can
lower the required dose of a
pharmacological intervention if you can
lower the exposure necessary with some
type
of neurofeedback or neurostim like a tms
or a tdcs or any
of these other tools if you're able to
lower the required doses
of several things when they're used in
combination and get
a similar or better outcome
it just has such incredible
ramifications for the
for the clinical use of these things
let's take a step back here so now we've
covered
a bunch of the research we've covered a
bunch of
the sort of tactical practical
implementations of
some of the research findings now i want
to paint a picture for people who don't
who don't know you at all so we've
already covered costello we have
not discussed the fact that you have
looks like full sleeve
tattoos on both arms
i think you're the i think you outed me
yeah there's that you're the first this
is the first yep
it's true all right birthmark they're
all birthmarks
of course they're all birthmarks kids
don't start because
they're like potato chips
and we may get to aquascaping that's a
whole separate conversation so we may
get to that but i want to
i want to rewind the clock for a second
because i read your bio
obviously very impressive bio you've
received numerous awards
you've produced a lot of incredible work
with
your colleagues and your your lab let's
go back
to what happened to you in july
of 1994 so in july of 1994
i was living in a little town called
isla vista which is near santa barbara
it's the home of uc santa barbara
university of california santa barbara
just as a little bit of background i was
not a good high school student
i had a very disrupted high school
experience
despite growing up in a in a good area
just a lot of
tension and and stuff at home so i
barely finished high school but i
followed a
high school girlfriend off to college
somehow i got in
at the time i wanted to be a firefighter
took fire science courses
at mission college in the south bay and
i thought i'd be a firefighter and i put
that in my entrance
exam and somehow they let me in but by
the end of my freshman year of college
i had terrible marks i had been
thrown out of the dormitory living for
getting in fights something i'm
certainly not proud of
and i was basically doing nothing that
summer i was living
in a i was squatting i was living in an
empty house
because a lot of the houses were empty i
figured why pay rent you know
living in an empty house with with my
pet ferret
and um to sort of set the context right
i was
i think i was still grappling with a lot
of anger
and resentment and confusion based on
having
a rather confusing teenage years and and
a lot of disruption
fortunately i'd formed a lot of
friendships and formed a community in
the skateboarding and punk rock culture
i was fortunate enough to get to know a
lot of guys that have gone on to do
great like my friend carl watson is an
adidas skateboarding i
i spent some time and got to know
although we weren't close friends with
the great danny way
probably the great one of the greatest
skateboarders of all time jumped the
great wall of china but i wasn't
a very good skateboarder i was not a
musician i knew how to do essentially
nothing
well and july 4th 1994
i went to a barbecue with some friends
and
some guys were robbing the house that we
were
having this party at we came back from
the store and we saw these guys
essentially
taking a bunch of possessions out of the
house and the thing
erupted into this big fight this huge
melee
i definitely went in excited to fight
i've been involved in fights before and
i had an
adrenaline seeking thing i felt like it
was justified
i'm certainly not encouraging anybody
else to do this but essentially what
happened was my friends took off
my so-called friends took off and i
ended up in a fight with like four or
five guys
knives came out bottles it's the sort of
thing where quickly you realize
that things could go badly wrong
fortunately
i stayed on two feet and nobody got
badly hurt or killed
the police showed up and actually
because of the fact that they were
robbing us
they actually congratulated me i'll
never forget this is actually what made
me feel
worst of all one of the police officers
said you know like nice work or
something like that and i
and i just realized that i was in
serious trouble
you know i'm 19 i barely finished high
school
i barely scraped through my first year
of college i'm living in a squat with my
ferret
my girlfriend had left me i didn't do
anything well
i didn't know how to do anything well
and so that day
and i still have this letter i actually
sat down
and i wrote a letter to myself and to my
parents
saying that i was gonna turn things
around i don't know why i wrote to them
because at the time i was kind of
avoiding contact with them entirely i've
since formed a really good relationship
with both my parents
but i decided that day
that i would use the one power that i
seem to have which is to remember facts
and information
and what i did was i i left santa
barbara i took a leave of absence went
back it went to
a local community college in the bay
area i did two quarters there
and i just started studying like a
maniac
first psychology then biology i
eventually fell in love with
neuroscience and related themes of
endocrinology and
and the rest is sort of history in terms
of eventually going to graduate school
and
getting a phd and becoming a professor
tenure and all that stuff
but it was one of those moments where i
realized
i am no longer going to be a young
screw-up i'm going to be a 20-year-old
screw-up
and with time people are going to be
less and less forgiving
and whatever had happened prior no one's
gonna care
it doesn't even really matter and if i
do want people to care and it's not like
i have a need to talk about the
challenges early on but
i need to get my act together i need to
do something i need to get good at
something
and so i became a kind of a maniac
actually when i read your your book the
four-hour work week in the
and the four-hour body which i read and
loved and own
i should say again not for sake of
flattery because they but they really
helped me they're a lot of useful tools
in there
there were certain things that resonated
i figured out that
if i drank a lot of coffee and took
certain supplements i could focus for
many hours
and then if i worked out i built another
capacity and if i ran i built another
capacity for endurance and
and i started to explore the crossovers
between
weightlifting is one thing it's not
about building muscles or
necessarily maybe it's about that it's
about really
moving against a physical force in real
time and really learning how to do that
endurance work is about learning how to
push through a different kind of barrier
and learning the carryover and crossover
points so i was the guy that would sit
down at my desk i move i decided to live
alone in a studio apartment
and i would set a timer for several
hours and i wouldn't allow myself to get
up
i was allowed to listen to rancid best
band ever for me on repeat and bob dylan
that's all i wouldn't even allow myself
to change music and then i would just
sit there and i would
read my textbooks underline my textbooks
write my textbooks and i just decided
i'm going to get straight a marks i'm
going to go to graduate school i'm going
to get a phd
i should imagine there were people that
came along at various times and helped
me
role models mentors people that spotted
that but it started with a switch that
flipped on july 4th 1994
and getting in a bad fight and here i am
deciding to choose a different path so i
want to
underscore or explore a few things and i
really appreciate you sharing this
because
i think it's very easy for people
listening to
folks with a bio like yours
to sort of assume a certain trajectory
to assume that it has always come easy
and that
you've always since you were two years
old known exactly which direction you
were heading which is not the case
one clarification with uc santa barbara
this might be an important point it
might not you did not
drop out you took a leave of absence is
that right is that material to the story
because i know in a lot of cases
there are folks who are kind of painted
as dropouts but
in fact they kept their options open by
taking the leave of absence
instead so i just want to clarify
yes a leave of absence is a mechanism
that most universities have
i think it was a design for things like
family situations if somebody
gets pregnant or they have a family
member who's sick that allows you to
leave and come back
and it's distinctly different from
dropping out although i was pretty close
to dropping out
of being forced to drop out for reasons
related to poor grades and poor behavior
fortunately that didn't happen i think
it's a really important point because we
hear that
bill gates dropped out of college steve
jobs dropped out of college mark
zuckerberg dropped out of college
i think maybe it was ryan holiday who i
don't know who said something like that
the people who are doing poorly in
college they're the ones that should
stay in college
because it's the one environment where
everything's scripted out for you what
you need to do in order to hit the next
metric of success and a leave of absence
is very different none of those people
dropped out of college
they took leave of absences that gave
them an insurance
policy that they could go back if they
wanted to
and it's very hard to make it back into
a system of any kind but it certainly is
much harder if you completely divorce
yourself
from that system i am a believer in
formal
rigorous coursework i am a university
professor i know that college isn't
perfect for everybody it
might even be the wrong decision for
certain people but if you're
still uncertain about what you want to
do
i think if it can be arranged
financially and it's
in the scope of things that somebody
might want to do i think learning how to
sit down in a chair
and force yourself to learn and then
compete with others in terms of how well
you learn that information i think is a
great way to evaluate oneself early in
life
and it sets the stage right i agree with
that
if you're open to it and certainly you
can say no
or we can talk about it and then you can
elect to have it edited out of the
conversation but
you mentioned tension and stuff at home
disruption
are you open to sharing a bit more
detail
about what you mean when you say those
things
sure so i had a pretty magical childhood
really uh my dad's a scientist my mom
wrote children's books and was a teacher
we ate dinner as a family everybody
together in the early part of my life i
acknowledged that i had great privilege
in having that experience and
growing up where i did good schools good
public schools i completely acknowledged
the benefits of that
especially early in life around 13 when
i was 13
my parents split up and either because
of the time in which it happened
or because they weren't equipped with
the right tools
there was a complete fracture of that
picture my dad was very much out of the
picture
at that time my mom hit
i think a series of challenges adjusting
i think it was a
what could only be described as a major
depression i think her view of family
was one in which everyone stuck together
no matter what she's from the east coast
she's from new jersey
like you stick together that's why we
had an argument the other day i don't
think she might be selling this and like
we got on and we were like ready to
scrap and we haven't had one of those in
years
but i just remembered that at the end of
this conversation we're gonna be okay
and at the end we were we were closer
so we both have that and i think for her
the fact that there was a complete
disintegration of the picture my sister
out of the house my dad out of the house
and me there she really hit the skids
and home became a very empty
very quickly became a very empty and
depressing place it was really
it was just really sad and i found
care and love and community in the world
of
skateboarding this was the early 90s and
there was this collection of
mostly young guys at that time who had
aggregated embarcadero plaza just in
hermann plaza in san francisco
i started going up there and hanging out
at the it's now the famed emb
for it's kind of got a golden era
reputation now
and that's where i learned that you
don't have to go to school there are a
lot of guys not going to school
there was a lot of drinking a lot of
drug use
a lot of wild behavior but also i should
say a lot of
amazing skateboarding and amazing
characters and
personalities and fights and everything
it was true street life and so i started
staying there i'd stay at people's
houses or sometimes we'd even sleep
there
and i learned a lot about how people
outside the
cozy suburbs of the south bay how they
lived
i'm grateful for that because it exposed
me to the fact that many of these kids
had no parental oversight from any age
that they had to scrap for everything
but quickly
i realized that i wasn't very good at
skateboarding i didn't have a
future in it and i wasn't going to
school my home life was really disrupted
and i lapsed into a pretty serious
depression
i just remember and anyone who's
experienced depression i i hope this
will resonate with although i
i'm sorry that it exists but there's
this weird thing about depression
which is that it changes your actual
view of the world i remember leaving
embarcadero
sometimes and looking up at the sky back
then they had the embarcadero freeway
and thinking the sky is so sad
like not the sky is a third as in
separate object but that this scene of
this sunset is so sad
and actually yesterday i was thinking
about this because there's this
beautiful sunset where i live and i
thought
gosh i haven't felt sad at the view of
the
natural world in so long it's and so
it's clearly a shift in my internal
state
and fast forward what happened was
eventually
the school picked up on the fact my high
school picked up on the fact that i
wasn't going
they called me in at some point i was
sitting down with a school counselor
and they had this guy in the room with
me
sitting there and pretty soon i realized
that i
was in a different kind of situation and
i realized they were going to probably
try and take me away because i was
completely truant i hadn't gone to
school
i was clearly depressed so that's what
happened
against my will and despite an attempt
to run away
i was taken to a place up the peninsula
which was neither a juvenile hall
nor a psychiatric hospital but we were
under lock and key
and i was in there with kids that had
dealt with everything from sexual abuse
to
hardcore substance abuse issues
i'll never forget this they said the
kids in the in the ward next door
they're crazy because they're really
young and the adults in the ward on the
other side they're crazy
but you guys you're not crazy and i
thought well that's
ridiculous because they're probably
saying the same thing to the ones on the
other side
but i had no one to call i called my
skateboard team manager
out of sympathy not because i was any
good i got put on a
on a wheel company in a truck company
for skateboarding and i called the guy
and i said i don't know what to do i'm
in this place and
and he i'll never forget he said look
i can barely take care of myself and
you're the most normal guy
i know and i've realized at that point
i'm like i'm really alone here so
the long and short of it was i did the
work i put my trust in the counselors
that were there they seemed like good
people
and you know i did the work but it's
part of an agreement
for getting let back into school
actually as part of an agreement for
being let out
i had to do weekly therapy and i was
fortunate enough that i got placed
working with somebody who understood my
particular needs worked with adolescents
and really encouraged me to start
exploring
my mind certainly the situation i was in
but encouraged me to start meditating he
gave me john kabat-zinn's book wherever
you go there you are
he saw how much physical energy i had
and he encouraged me to start
running i was always hurting myself
skateboarding and he said well maybe
running or swimming and running and
swimming are amazing because
unless you really do it wrong you can go
and go and go it's just an
i could burn off all that anger and
energy over time
and then i started getting into
weightlifting and and the weightlifting
is kind of a double-edged sword i should
mention i think it's one of those things
that
is great but you know if you exceed a
certain size
it can actually make people kind of
scare of you sort of like the tattoos
thing
a lot of like a lot of the reason why i
cover up tattoos is because then people
just see the
see your tattoos but it's true i started
getting tattooed pretty young
the wrong way don't do it this way with
india inc and a needle this was before
autoclaves bad don't do it but i decided
at that age
that the therapy and this one person who
seemed to really care about my
mental and physical well-being and would
spend the time was really worth
investing in and i hid it from everybody
because no one did therapy then no one
talked about it
it's like late 80s early 90s nobody did
that and i will confess
i don't think i've ever said this
publicly but i've found
a way either through insurance or
through my own income i've continued
therapy with that same individual now
for
32 years wow
and so i do i confess i do three
sessions a week
of psychoanalysis remote or in person
and i know people have a lot of they do
the other kind of eye roll not the
spiegel eye roll test but the other kind
of viral when you say psychoanalysis
i think an exploration of the mind is
extremely powerful
it has to be done with the right person
and there's only one person i know who's
done this kind of extended work for so
many years and that's the late oliver
sacks
who's a kind of a hero of mine also
worked with a psychoanalyst for many
many years and
so psychoanalysis a fight on
on july 4th 1994 a lot of attempt
to both stabilize my mind and also
organize my behavior those things go
hand in hand of course but also
biology to leverage i guess you could
call it biohacking you call it i just
call it biology i mean
when i learned for instance that taking
a thousand milligrams per day of epa
essential fatty acids
not just fish oil but getting above that
threshold is as effective
as antidepressants in double-blind
placebo-controlled studies
you know when i saw those papers i
realized well
i probably have a bit of a leaning
toward depression i'm going to do that
now did i do that and drop therapy no i
do that in therapy and i train and i try
and work on my sleep it's a constant
process but
biology and the information contained in
books like yours and and hopefully in
the information that i'm trying to put
out into the world now
that stuff helps in a major way too so
it was a multi-pronged
support system and uh many incredible
mentors along the way but
i was definitely at the edge i know
you've talked about this publicly too i
i mean there were times when i just
thought
like why continue and i'm fortunate
nowadays i feel
very far from that there's a saying in
the world of addiction
and addiction treatment which is that no
matter how far you drive you're always
the same distance from the ditch
that i would say is true of addiction
fortunately
at least in my own experience that is
not true of depression
i have vowed to never go back to a place
where living seems meaningless
and anyone who's been close to that
place all i can say is
the work works whether or not it's
therapy biology etc
you have to do it and there are things
that can accelerate that process
but it's an ongoing battle to be honest
well you're fighting the good fight man
i'm certainly right in there with you
how does it feel to talk about this
stuff it's interesting i always get a
little quake
on this i would say there are only two
things that will always consistently
make me cry
and those are the thought of i don't
even want to talk about for too long
because i prefer not to cry but one it
would be uh when my bulldog costello
goes that we're very bonded and he's
close unfortunately so he's in his final
years and the other is when i think
about
my mentors in particular one passing
away
talking about this gets me in a mode
where it's uncomfortable
i'm definitely uncomfortable at this
moment i'm okay to talk about it because
i think these issues are important and i
wholeheartedly believe that many people
struggle with them you know i'm always
conscious of protecting the people in my
life who
were doing the best they could with what
they had so you know my parents are
good people that generation didn't have
the tools that i had access to and
i do hope the next generation and we'll
have access to more tools
so i want to protect them they they are
you know i'm blessed
i acknowledge my privilege i and i don't
say that for political reasons by the
way i just want to say i acknowledge
that
i was born into a pretty fortunate or
very fortunate situation
that provided buffers and i only know my
own experience but i
acknowledge it as real thanks for
sharing all that
and a mutual friend has prompted me
to ask about the hoffman process
oh yeah the hoffen process so the
hoffman process
is a it's a personal development process
it's a full immersion
week-long process i think it used to be
two weeks i don't want to give away too
much about it because if one were to go
you want to have the experience for the
first time without expecting
or knowing what's coming it involves a
lot of both physical
and kind of emotional purging and what's
interesting is
it's generally between 20 and 40 people
go
you don't publicly share any of the
issues that you're grappling with
there is a teacher there that you
communicate with and who knows a lot
about your situation there's a lot of
work that you do beforehand and
paperwork so they really know closely
what you're
grappling with and you do get to know
people there but there are strict rules
no romantic relationships no discussion
of politics no discussion of work no
discussion of sports and you quickly
find
that you realize that you spend a lot of
time thinking about and talking about
those things in the outside world
and b that there are other ways to
connect with people that are very
authentic
that don't involve those things hoffman
process was one of several things for me
that was transformative for me it was
most transformative in the realm
of forgiveness i felt
completely resolved of my challenges
with you know inability to focus
complete work structure etc i had solved
all that
i learned how to work hard perform well
by time i went to hoffman which was
in my early 40s i'm 45 now i learned how
to
control my physical landscape as best as
one
could or should i went there thinking
like why would i go here
what's the purpose in going and yet i i
realized that
i harbored a lot of resentment
mostly toward family members but also
toward
experiences and and people outside my
family
and i i almost got kicked out of hoffman
the first day not for misbehavior but
because i slept through the first day
i'd been working so hard they kept
saying
you're trying to escape by sleeping and
i'm like i'm just tired
like they take really good care of they
take really good care of you there i've
actually never
felt so nurtured i'm not somebody who
accepts nurturing very easily
um i like to think i'm more of a
caretaker and a more of a kind of
caretaker loner type than
being taken care of and hoffman they i
felt comfortable to be taken care of
in certain ways and i discovered in
doing the work that there were all these
resentments
and i was able to purge those
resentments and
i have to say it completely erased
all feelings that i was wronged by
anybody
or anything and that's powerful and it's
completely behavioral nature there's no
pharmacology there
i would say hoffman is among the two or
three things that or maybe four or five
things that were really
transformative for me and there is a
price point but they do have a
scholarship program
that's been established thanks to the
generosity of
various folks so for people that can't
afford the price point they do have a
fairly simple scholarship program where
you write something out people who are
practitioners
you know therapists and in the wellness
community i think also get a break of
some sort i have no business
relationship to hoffman but
i've recommended that several people go
and it is powerful
and it does last in fact the reason i
decided to go to hoffman was because
somebody actually a mutual friend of
ours tim
who i don't think went wendy yalum who i
know from way back when we haven't been
in touch in years but i think she said
something about hoffman and she said she
knew somebody who went and i contacted
that person
and that person said i went to hoffman
and 10 years later it still has a
profound positive effect on my life
and i found it to be more useful than
any other
therapy or training of any kind that's
my hofmann story and
it's powerful and for people who want to
hear more about hoffman i talk about it
at length also with blake mykoski
in the last conversation i had with him
so people can find
that that episode you mentioned one of
four or five
things what are some of the other things
that have had a
disproportionate positive impact this is
a broad category but get your biology
right
start with sleep figure it out figure
out how to get your sleep right because
it's the fundamental layer of mental
health
so get that one right other things in
the biological category are learn how to
focus
learn how to defocus learn how to flip
the switch on learn how to flip the
switch off
get good at sleeping of course exercise
of various kinds is going to be good and
all the
other things but there's that physical
bin and those are the primary
levers there i do think some form
of exploration whether or not it's
psychoanalysis psychotherapy
journaling or some sort of internal
reflection
that's somewhat unregulated but
obviously not damaging to you or anyone
else so don't punch
concrete walls but have the ability to
sit down
and data dump and
reflect if you can't afford therapy
reflect
on what you're seeing and reading and
feeling have the ability to experience
what's internal so that'll be the second
one
the third one is and i realize there's
some issues around
legality and things and right now
everything's in transition
i was part of a clinical trial so i can
safely say this you know i do think
that there are certain aspects to
let's just call it what it is either
plant medicine or i was part of mdma
assisted psychotherapy trial
that was extremely valuable there's no
question
to me that that's a powerful mover
of one's ability to feel comfortable in
internal state the way i would
just briefly describe that experience
for me is that i could feel
and perfectly fine from here to here and
from the belly button down
but i had this feeling always that i
couldn't kind of
experience things in mind and body at
the same time i know this is going to
sound really
wacko to people who maybe haven't
experienced this but
somehow in that brief experience i was
able to resolve that and i
now experience my nervous system as a
complete entity
and i do not think people should cowboy
this stuff
and do it on their own or try and do
therapy for their friends or do this on
their own i don't think this is
something that people should play around
with these are very powerful tools you
should do this with a board certified md
sign up for a clinical trial hopefully
this will be
done in the you know in these sorts of
medical settings soon
legally and you don't have to be part of
a clinical trial but
if you struggle ongoing in some way i do
think there's utility there so that's
another bin
and then there's another bin which for
me has been very powerful which is
stay on the adventure continue to have
fun it's so easy to forget to have fun
when you're doing all these other things
like stay in the adventure and
don't get killed um doing it but
you know really try and keep exploring i
do believe these dopamine systems
are positively reinforced by novelty and
exploration we know that
and by venturing into new territories
and that
requires getting certain things wrong it
means going to a retreat that sucks
it means taking a class that is not
that interesting it means finding out
that
you know a particular relationship is
not right for you but
it's important to stay in a mode of
adventure because that's fundamental to
the human experience and it's
fundamental to these neurochemical
systems as well
a couple of points i'd love to
underscore
here so the biological piece
you've discussed in other places this
principle
it's a quote of sorts a maxim that i
think is
really worth remembering and i'm saying
that to myself as much to anyone
listening that is you cannot control the
mind with the mind and
whether or not there might be exceptions
to that i think is a general rule
using the bi-directionality as you've
mentioned
of sort of body mind mind body and
you know when in doubt working through
your
fuller biology is incredibly
powerful i mean for me like to get out
of my head
i need to get into my body there's just
no
metacognitive way generally for me to
otherwise do that or if there is it's
just
much more difficult i've even told my
girlfriend i'm like if i'm trying to
figure out
what is bothering me and i spend more
than like a half hour on it
just tell me to go to the gym and lift
heavy things for at least 30 minutes
the best best remedy in the world
and then i come out i'm like yeah that
bullshit's fine it doesn't matter
and that's what was necessary on the
adventure side
actually before i get to the adventure
side just a quick note
on costello because i think a lot about
my dog molly and mortality and it's just
it's
like so easy to get sad and
how old is she she's seven but she's had
some health issues she's had two spinal
surgeries
and if you haven't looked into the
canine research with rapamycin
i would look into that it's very very
compelling
so that might be thank you i'll do that
i listened to your podcast with peter
tia and uh yeah a lot of discussion
about rap myosin i i'll definitely check
it out
yeah it's it's worth checking out
there's also a separate episode with
david sabatini of mit who
is a genius and an and a sort of
mtor wizard uh who's that family
he has a brother bernardo sabatini who's
a famous neurobiologist at harvard
who i know quite well and their dad
there's another sabatini
who was at nyu med so those sabbatinis
they're kind of like the kornbergs
kornberg discovered rna
his son discovered the structure of rna
they both got nobels and i think their
brother is an immunologist or something
like that
so yeah if you're last if you're
thinking about changing your last name
sabatini or kornberg is a good one to
to select yeah not not not bad yeah they
come from the
secretariat stock the scientific gene
pool
on the adventure side so you said don't
die or don't let something
kill you which i think is a perfect
segue to
as i'm reading it from a paragraph from
outside magazine
huberman was about 40 miles off the
coast of mexico and 40 feet below the
periwinkle surface of the ocean
what does this refer to oh my yeah so
before i went to hoffman i was still
working out some things
the quick backstory of this is in 2016
i decided i was going to shift a lot of
my laboratory work toward humans
i understand the issues of animal
research and why it's important
my lab still does work on mice because
there's certain things you can only do
on mice but i want to work on humans
and i want to use virtual reality to
induce fear in the laboratory
and study stress and fear and other
brain states and
we realized that vr as it stood at the
time was just
pretty lame it was computer generated
images it didn't have 360 video or sound
and so i got linked up with a guy named
michael muller
mull er who's a very very famous
photographer in hollywood mostly does
all the marvel
stuff he shot everybody that you just go
to his website it's just it's kind of a
just a constant scroll of iconic images
mueller and i got to be friends
and the reason i was excited about
getting to know him is because
a hobby of his is that he takes photos
of great white sharks
underwater he brings these giant strobe
lights underwater
and mueller is you know you hear about
the character the wolverine hugh jackman
right mueller is a wolverine he's kind
of hunched over
and he's the nicest guy in the world but
it was like
it was immediate friendship but he loves
adventure he's got
he's got a family kids everything but he
loves adventure and he said
this is my best mueller impersonation
he's like bro you gotta come down to
guadalupe the sharks are there
and i was like well what are we gonna do
he said well we'll just film them with
360 cameras
so in 2016 we went down there
and we filmed great white sharks as a
stimulus for this fear laboratory that
we were building
and got 360 video and the way we did
that was that
mueller and a couple other guys these
expert great white shark divers would
leave the cage you lower the cage about
40 feet below and they leave the cage to
come back in so called cage exiting
definitely illegal to do we got permits
from the mexican government because this
was for a scientific study
i would have loved to see that
permitting process anyway continue
that was something else so we we got the
footage brought it back built this thing
up and then what happened was in the
subsequent year
the technology for vr really improved so
we decided we were going to go back
and i decided for whatever reason
that i was going to cage exit also i
actually learned how to scuba dive for
the first trip but i had stayed in the
cage
and so the second trip we went out there
and i brought a good friend of mine
who's actually a mutual friend through
blake
mykoski pat dossett is a former former
seal team guy
i brought brian mckenzie because brian
learned
brian mckenzie learned how to scuba dive
in a lake
in oregon and his first ocean dive was
cage exit with great whites now of
course the guy has unscared tattooed on
his knuckles i know he was
uh featured in in a number of your your
books so it's brian pat me and some
other guys we went out there with the
intention of getting better footage
to create a very realistic vr experience
of great white sharks
so what happened was on the first day i
decided i'm not going to cage exit today
let pat go he's the seal team guy he'll
do it he did it of course masterfully
the first time
went a few meters beyond everybody
because those guys aren't competitive or
anything
anyway it all worked out but the first
day i was in the cage
so i went down i've been in the cage
before and you're breathing off a hookah
line which is up to the surface you're
not on scuba and the reason you don't
bring scuba is because you don't want to
take up too much space in the cage
so the other divers muller and a couple
other guys had left the cage
and i was there just watching the sharks
and really enjoying it i'd been down
there the previous year and
these great white sharks their girth
isn't incredible and they come at you
unlike a volkswagen and they'll stop
right in front of you and hover
they'll eyeball you and then disappear
into the darkness
it's really amazing and i realized as i
was down there i'm like i'm
alone in the cage this time i've never
been alone in the cage
we had a lot of sharks that day so i was
moving around and swiveling around a lot
and then all of a sudden i had no air
nothing just nothing coming through the
mouthpiece
and i looked up and the hookah line got
all boa constrictored up
so i popped up to it thinking oh just
untangle this thing and it's like hard
as
concrete it's like oh good so i took
another suck of air
and nothing and i looked down there's
safety tanks in the two corners
so i spit out the mouthpiece i drop down
to the safety tanks open them up
and the needle doesn't move they're
empty oh god
this is like the biggest nightmare and
it's interesting
we were talking about costello i had one
thought
at that moment a totally inefficient use
of mental space
but the one thought was i'm going to go
home
alive i'm going to see costello he just
popped into my head
so this stuff really does happen
apparently so
nothing off the safety tanks so i
decided
i got to get out of here when there's
sharks everywhere
but i've got to get to the surface and
you're just desperate for air so
i pop up to the top of the tank and i've
got a weight vest on
and i've got to take that weight vest
off if i want to get up to the surface
now the sharks actually don't eat you
when you're outside the cage
if you're swimming toward them they
actually if you loom on them they steer
away that's the way that these cage
exit divers are able to avoid getting
eaten
or if you're ocean ramsay you just kind
of understand them and you swim next to
them
but i was genuinely frightened and
stressed and so
i thought okay i'm going to shoot for
the surface i could see the silhouette
of the boat i'm going to shoot for the
surface
i'll either get eaten or i'll drown but
i'm
certain i'll drown if i stay here and
then what happened was
one of the divers his name's brock saw
me
and started kicking back toward me and
he's carrying this big vacuum cleaner
size
vr thing and that felt like an eternity
you know he's coming back to me back to
me slowly so i'm just hoping
if i pass out i want to fall into the
cage if i float i want to make sure i
float up but
it was a good 20 or 30 more seconds
which doesn't sound like very long but
it's not like that sounds like an
eternity
it was an eternity so he made it back we
did the share
error thing but then we had a whole
other problem which was that
we're sharing air those guys are out
there we're now on one tank
and the safeties are empty so now
there's a chance that we both might have
to shoot for the surface
so fortunately everybody made it back in
time and we got up to the surface
but i will never forget that experience
i do feel like i'm on borrowed time and
i did
feel quite traumatized by it and i will
say that that night i did
one thing and the next day i did
something else was that night i
i was able to sleep i did yoga nidra and
i was able to calm
my mind and my nerves and the next day
because i i understand a bit about the
relationship between trauma and exposure
i did go back down the very next day and
i cage exited
and some people might think that's
foolish i certainly didn't do it to be
tough or just
seem like i'm tough i did it because
facing the trauma
is the best way to purge the trauma we
know this
and kj exiting for me allowed me i
believe to report the experience i feel
nothing in my body no tension no stress
no quaking or anything related to that
so i do think it's been completely
purged
i want to dig into what i read as
a definition of fear from you and just
to hear more about
your fascination with fear and where it
comes from so here's what i have
and you can fact check this please quote
fear it's the anxiety that you feel when
you don't know what behavior can remove
a feeling of helplessness in the face of
a threat
end quote does that sound right to you
you can't have stress without anxiety
you can't have trauma without stress but
you can have
stress or anxiety without trauma i think
that the key variables
are anxiety is a state of heightened
alertness
it's contracting the visual field
quickening of the heart rate breathing
all the kind of standard stuff that we
hear of sympathetic nervous system
activation
but the mental component is one in which
time is being sliced very finely so
you're constantly anticipating and
evaluating your environment
and your internal state because
oftentimes people are aware of
their so-called interoception they're
keenly aware of how nervous they are or
upset they are
and this element of uncertainty of being
unable to predict when it's going to
pass
and this creates a kind of meta stress
it's sort of like when people have
trouble sleeping
then they create this kind of meta
anxiety and insomnia they're now they're
stressed about not sleeping and so then
it makes it even harder to sleep the
same thing with stress
the more we stress the more we want the
stress to pass and
i think that resolving the uncertainty
element is powerful and i think it
starts by taking control
of the mind through the route of the
body
when our mind is not stable whatever
that means but we're not able to control
our mental state
or it's not where we'd like it to be we
need to look to the powers of
respiration of vision
of movement of weight training of
running to reorient the mind i think it
is futile
to try and rescue thinking with thinking
that's not to say that thinking and an
exploration of the mind like with
psychoanalysis or journaling is not
powerful
but for restabilizing our system
these brain states of mind and body i
think the body is the more powerful
entry point and have you always been
fascinated by fear or why
why did that become a focal point
probably because i was the kid that was
last to drop in on the ramp
probably because i have lived and
existed with
a fair amount of fear this seems to have
gotten
better over the years for instance i can
remember skateboarding home
there's this bike path that used to
connect the school that i went to the
back of some houses and i would push
back
through there at night and i would start
to imagine that
terrible things were going to happen to
me i think that fear was it was a
strong default and i can't assign that
to any earlier experience
i think i just had a lot of baseline
anxiety and fear
and so resolving that and figuring out
tools that people could use
that i could use also to resolve those
things really fast has been a major
a major effort in my life including my
laboratory i'd like to if it's okay with
you shift gears a little bit and just
pepper you with a bunch of random
questions
that have absolutely no continuity with
anything we just talked about
great that's okay sure thing
all right because i just i have this
scratch pad full of these various things
that i want to ask about
often without a whole lot of context
just from from various reading and so on
so
turmeric's effects on dht could you
elaborate
on this so dht dihydrotestosterone i'm
guessing
what should we know about dht and
turmeric's effects on dht
and i ask in part because it's something
that i use all the time in cooking
there's seems to be some research to
suggest that
products like theracumin i believe it's
called as the brand name
might attenuate some risk related to say
neurodegenerative disease or alzheimer's
so i'd love to know more about this
yeah so brief endocrinology lesson on
testosterone dht testosterone is
the androgen of course that's
responsible for
muscle growth deepening the voice
regression sex drive etc
but dht dihydrotestosterone is made from
testosterone
through an enzyme called 5-alpha
reductase dht is the more powerful
androgen anywhere from 300 to 600 times
the affinity for the androgen receptor
dht is the and its affinity for the
androgen receptor
not so incidentally is the basis of
nandrolone deca
known in gym circles actually a female
runner that was
a good pick for the 1500 just got a
four-year ban
oops or an angelone positive test
she claims and her coach claims that it
came from a
burrito containing pork with nangalon i
actually
would love somebody to go explore we're
going to see more of this in the years
to come
i'd like somebody to actually analyze
meat for clenbuterol and andrew alone to
just see
because i they and i'm not happy that
this happened
it's a sad situation but we could fairly
say that there's been a dark shadow cast
by a burrito
over the olympic uh qualifications um
it's kind of like when all the sprinters
were diagnosed as narcoleptics you
remember that with
oh really medicinal yeah they're all in
the daffodil on various stimulants and
so they had these scripts from their
doctors and letters saying they were all
narcoleptics it's just amazing
the venn diagram to get them quick out
the blocks that's where the race is won
hear that gun and get out the blocks
that's so nandrolone is deca
the reason people take it uh whether or
not she took or not i don't know but the
reason people take it is because
dht as the more powerful androgen with
this higher affinity
is the one that's mainly responsible for
libido and many of the cognitive effects
of testosterone
one of the more powerful effects of
testosterone is that because of
the fact that there are androgen
receptors in the amygdala
that it has a fear-suppressing component
to it
and dht testosterone but really dht
has a property of making effort feel
good
that's probably the main psychological
effect of testosterone aside from its
effects on
on libido and the body periphery so
some people are very dht sensitive if
you're somebody for instance that takes
creatine
and experiences hair loss very quickly
you're probably dht sensitive that's
because creatine increases dht
dht will promote hair loss on the scalp
like my hairline is retreating quite
nicely and now
because of dht receptors here and it
promotes beard growth so it has
these inverse effects on the face and on
the scalp but
turmeric is a fairly potent dht
antagonist now whether or not it does
that by occupation of the androgen
receptor or some other mechanism i don't
know
people will vary in their sensitivity i
am very sensitive to turmeric
if i take turmeric my dht levels plummet
and i'm not taking dandrulone
nor am i eating pork burritos
but the the sensitivity will vary and
you can kind of predict that sensitivity
by how you react to creatine if you're
somebody that takes low doses of
creatine which
many people do and experience hair loss
chances are when you take turmeric
you're going to see a reduction in dht
means that your five alpha reductase
system and or this interaction between
turmeric and the androgen receptor are
for whatever reason more sensitive in
you some people
take turmeric and feel perfectly fine i
noticed a
an immediate blunting of all the good
stuff let's say
that dht and testosterone do when i take
even a minimum of turmeric now that
doesn't mean i can't have a little bit
of turmeric and a drink like a juice
drink or something
but dosing turmeric is not something
that i do or that i recommend for for
people
now women do make a little bit of dht it
might be a whole different
story with them but i i think for men
you probably just want to do the
experiment it's quickly reversible if
you stop taking turmeric so you could
evaluate this
some people will be fine you could do a
blood test you could do it subjectively
is uh finasteride propecia that is often
used for
mitigating hair loss that is i think
it's a five
alpha reductase inhibitor
would that also have the effect of
decreasing
dht levels i want to say they're
anecdotal reports and
people please do your own homework go to
go to pubmed and do some research but
i want to say that least among strength
athletes that i've heard anecdotal
reports of
propecia use correlating to
decreases in strength gains for male
athletes
yeah absolutely and it certainly can
reduce dht levels certainly more for
those that are sensitive to it
just to underscore how powerful dht is
we have what are called
primary and secondary sex
characteristics secondary sex
characteristics are like body hair
deepening the voice etc
but the primary characteristics like the
presence of a penis or not
and this is independent of gender this
is just biological sex it's encoded by
the y chromosome
that's entirely controlled by dht during
development
and masculinization of the brain is a
separate pathway
but there's this phenomenon that i think
is in the dominican republic a
genetic disruption in some of these
pathways and there that people can look
this up the so-called huevidosis
this is a famous story in endocrinology
of children that look female at birth by
genitalia and then because of a surge in
dht later
they literally sprout a penis at about
and testicles descend
at about age 12 whoever doses wow
and there's a whole story there it
actually was part of the story that
helped
neuro endocrinologists and developmental
biologists understand
the role of five alpha reductase in
testosterone's conversion to dht
fascinating biology there
much too much to go into now in detail
but people can look it up online
dht is powerful in development and it's
powerful throughout the lifespan
so you you want to keep levels of dht
appropriately high
but don't take an angelone if you're
sprinting in the olympics so that's not
the way to get your
uh loan is not the way to get your dht
yeah
even if you do get it through through
anabolic piggies
just it's just like there's so many more
cost-effective ways
to make pigs grow deca durable and
injections is probably not high on the
list
they need natty menus right they need
menus that are like
if you're olympic athlete please just
prepare your own food yeah
yeah yeah exactly so so many directions
to go here
it makes me wonder also if anyone has
looked at
turmeric or curcumin or whatever the
actual compound is responsible for this
dht inhibition whether it's vf5 alpha
reductase or otherwise
on pregnancy and birth gender
i'm wondering if that would have any
effect if dht is suppressed
in a woman who is pregnant if that would
have any effect
on earth gender yeah that's a topic that
i don't think the experiment's ever been
done but my postdoc advisor
ben barris was transgendered and it's an
interesting story
briefly he was an identical twin
he from a very early age he felt
entirely uncomfortable
in a female body he knew he wanted to be
male from a very young age long before
puberty
his sister who i've interacted with as
well is perfectly happy
being a woman enjoys being a woman and
they're identical twins and their
mother was actually treated with an
androgenic drug during pregnancy
ben unfortunately passed away with
pancreatic cancer a few years ago
he was an incredibly accomplished
neuroscientist and physician
his name is barris b-a-r-r-e-s there are
a number of
obituaries i i wrote one for nature that
you know describes his his life and
his transition and some of the biology
but
nonetheless ben and i spent about a year
before he died i
recorded a lot of conversations with ben
that i haven't released yet talking
about what it was like to be
a girl what it was like to be a woman
what it was like to be a man
later in life just as i he's a close
friend of mine i want to understand that
and he described that
this was an immediate effect as soon as
he knew there was a difference between
boys and girls he knew that he was in
the wrong body
he he likened it to if you woke up
tomorrow and you were in a gorilla's
body
that's how uncomfortable it was knowing
that's how he described it
and he thought that perhaps you know
this early androgenic drug treatment
might have
shaped his brain differently than his
sister somehow
raises so many so many interesting
questions about
you know phytoestrogens or sort of these
xenoestrogens and the environmental
inputs that could affect that entire
biochemical cocktail to different
different outputs
testosterone so we've talked a little
bit about dht there's a goldilocks range
depending on your gender and your
objectives
for testosterone are there any
particular
supplements that you use to i hesitate
to use this word because it's so
goal dependent but to optimize your
testosterone or dht
levels or reduce sex hormone binding
globulin or whatever
if you're sort of toying with your
androgens how do you like to do it
optimizing and or understanding
testosterone i think is
is vital for men and women because it's
so powerful
obviously get your sleep right that's an
important one and you do that through so
that's an indirect effect
stress keep stress chronic stress to a
minimum that's an indirect effect
train hard but not too long that's an
indirect effect mostly
in the supplementation space there are
two things that
have worked very well for me and that
i've recommended to a number of people
that have worked well for them and those
two things
are tongat ali which at
400 milligrams per day is
thought to reduce sex hormone binding
globulin because if for those that don't
know testosterone can exist in a free or
bound form
people hear binding globulins and they
bind up testosterone and prevent free
testosterone they think this is terrible
but actually albumin and sex hormone
binding globulin
are wonderful because they ensure that
whatever testosterone you make
will be delivered to your tissues over a
long period of time and different
tissues need different amounts of
testosterone
and so you don't want to plummet sex
hormone binding globulin but tonga ali
either through reducing sex hormone
binding globulin
or through direct effects on increasing
androgen
release will increase your testosterone
now the the way to explore this and i'm
not
saying anyone should do this you
definitely want to work with your
physician but the way to explore this is
400 milligrams per day taken once per
day
early in the day because it can have a
little bit of a stimulant effect
make you more alert that works well it
does need to be taken chronically it
tends to
work better as you get into the second
and third month of use
and i don't see any reason to cycle it
unless somehow
something's you know spikes on your
liver enzymes or something
the other supplement that is quite
useful
is phadoggia aggressis fedoja agrestis
is one of these
plant alkaloids that i think it comes
from a nigerian shrub
i might have that wrong but the doji
aggressis
acts as a luteinizing hormone mimic so
it actually stimulates the
testes to produce more testosterone so
it's like hcg
it's like a it's a bit like hcg but it
for whatever reason it doesn't seem to
increase estrogen
which is unique because hcg will
increase estrogen
now just anecdotally i started using
those in combination
so it's 400 milligrams of tonga ali i
have no
relationship to the company so i can
mention where i get it from although i
hope they don't sell out as a
they will sell out as a consequence a
solar ray makes a good
version of this sometimes these things
are packaged in with other things but
celery has a pure form
and then fedoja agrestus i think it's
herbal elixirs makes a fedojo aggressive
and some people make the mistake of
taking far too much fadoja aggresses
i think on the bottle they recommend
three two to three times a day
one 425 milligram capsule
i i believe is more than sufficient and
anecdotally for me what this did is it
it increased my total testosterone by
about 200 points
so i felt kind of in the middle of the
range i was neither high nor low i was
at about 600
hovering somewhere around 600 these two
supplements consistently bring it up
into the high sevens or low eights
which is in the direction that i wanted
to go do you think fedoja agrestis
if it is luteinizing hormone
similar meaning it's a mimic of sorts
do you think that would have any
i guess it probably would have a sort of
down regulating effect on
endogenous production of lh well what's
interesting is
when i've done my blood work twice a
year at least for me it did not down
regulate
lh which is nice because things like hcg
definitely would down regulate lh people
who take testosterone sipionate uh you
know t
so-called trt or similar we'll see a
down regulation in luteinizing hormone
so fodochia and tonga ali i i mentioned
because they're sort of an intermediate
between
doing nothing with respect to
supplements or taking things that don't
really work
there are a lot of those out there or
taking the full plunge into
trt and i'll just mention if i if i may
about trt there's a lot of
interest and excitement in trt they now
even have what's called
sports trt which is not and just for
people who who don't have the contacts
if i'm not sure if you if you already
kind of named it
out but testosterone replacement therapy
trt
so right what's what's sports trt is
this like med spa type stuff
yeah so um people are probably wondering
wait you're a neurobiologist why do you
know so much about this stuff well
i have the good fortune of doing work
with various high performing communities
and there's just a lot of discussion
around hormone and neural augmentation
and so i'm not making recommendations i
what i generally do with those
communities and what i'm doing now is
point people to the fact that there
there are things that lie somewhere
between doing nothing
and going the prescription drug route
eating pork burritos yeah exactly
exactly
in the realm of trt testosterone
replacement therapy the typical dosages
that people use are 160 to 200
milligrams a week
but the way it's administered doesn't
match the biology i think this is a
serious problem that needs to be dealt
with
typically if you get a prescription
you'll go in they'll give you one
injection of anywhere from 160 to 200
milligrams
and then you go back two weeks later and
you get another injection the testes
normally
make anywhere from about five to ten
milligrams of testosterone a day
so if you're taking 160 milligrams of
testosterone on one day
you're going to set in motion all sorts
of cascades of aromatization into
estrogen
conversion into dht that you might feel
terrible then great four days later and
then
so so two weeks later the way people are
doing this now more intelligently is to
do their injections at home either into
subcutaneously or into muscle and
every third or fourth day to take a low
dose of maybe
40 milligrams and to dose it more evenly
because these long lasting forms like
cipient do release over time
but sports trt is this intermediate
that's been created on the internet
where people are neither doing
testosterone replacement therapy
to get levels up to normal or high
normal nor are they doing what
the gym rats call blasting they're not
taking three four
five hundred they're taking 200 a week
or
300 a week and the amount of
self-directed pharmacology that's
happening out there is
pretty incredible and like i don't pass
judgment everybody it's your life to
live but
there are a lot of horror stories too
you can really mess yourself up by
getting androgen levels too high i'm a
fan
of gently moving into the
supplementation
space for this seeing how it works doing
a blood test
and then if people want to do trt over
time that's certainly they're right
that's not my place to judge and you
need you need a prescription anyway
so you have to talk to a doctor yeah and
just a couple of
additional thoughts on all this stuff
well first the
lower dose higher frequency regimen
can also be applied to to many things
right growth hormone would be another
example from the same sort of portfolio
of
interventions slash augmentations that a
lot of folks would use
and separately i would say and please
please feel free to correct me or fact
check on this but whether you're eating
pork burritos
injecting yourself with anabolics of
different types
or eating deer antler velvet or whatever
the latest
fad is that people claim increases
testosterone
if you dramatically increase your
testosterone levels
if you are not taking an anti-aromatase
you are also going to increase
your estrogen levels even though it
depends on the anabolic obviously
nandrollon's very different from
different types of testosterone and so
on
which some are more anabolic some are
more androgenic
but if you suddenly wallop yourself with
much higher
levels of testosterone you are also
going to a portion of that will be
converted to estrogen
and so it's just something to be aware
of right it's it's very hard to get a
biological free lunch uh and
and if you're if you're feeding yourself
a bunch of stuff and
your testes like these siberian what
were they albino rats
that this house hamsters yeah siberian
hamsters
if your balls go from whatever your
comfortable ball diameter is down to
like
raisins you may require post-cycle
therapy pct
various drugs to successfully
off-ramp from these types of
interventions unless
like some power lifters you're just
going to be loaded all year round 365 24
7 which
uh is obviously your your choice if you
want to do something like that but
i'm glad you could yeah good idea to get
medical medical supervision for all of
these definitely
and and along those lines i should just
mention well i will say that fedoja
tends to have the opposite effect on the
testicles it actually will cause it
fairly
not pronounced but it uh increases
testicle size
that's a pretty strong effect or media
effect of fedoja
the other thing is that right now
there's a lot of excitement about
peptides people are like oh
the so-called secreta gogs it sounds
like synagogue but it's secretag
which these are like not not taking
growth hormone but taking peptides that
promote growth hormone release and then
people are taking you know gastric
peptide this and
here's the deal things that make us
feel more vital like testosterone dht
growth hormone generally will shorten
your life
i know that's a bit of a controversial
statement but but if you step back and
use
just ask yourself what is the most vital
energetic phase of your life it's
puberty when all these hormones are
really
high and puberty is the most rapid
period of aging that any of us go
through
i was talking about this recently with a
longevity researcher and i
and it's kind of interesting that all
the longevity the attempts
at increasing lifespan are like starving
yourself which is catabolic
reducing blood sugar which is catabolic
and that's
on the opposite side of all these things
like testosterone which is anabolic
insulin which is anabolic growth hormone
which is anabolic and so
anabolism sounds like a great thing
although it does sound remarkably
similar to cannibalism
but growth and vitality libido strength
etc that all it sounds wonderful and in
its proper form
and context is wonderful but the reason
why i think we see people
dying early who do a lot of growth
hormone and testosterone is because
they've effectively created a third and
fourth round of puberty
you're accelerating aging and so i think
vitality and longevity always have to be
balanced with one another totally and
we could go for hours just on this one
topic one other
cautionary note well two actually number
one
unless you're type one diabetic don't
inject insulin there are athletes who do
this but you can very easily kill
yourself
the second is if you're taking a lot of
growth agents some of them are not
selective to skeletal muscle tissue
and you may as a male end up looking
like you're in your second trimester
from enlarged organs and guess what when
you get off of those drugs your organs
don't automatically resume their smaller
size
this is also why certain baseball
players and so on have gone up
multiple helmet sizes it's not from pork
burritos
those effects are durable you can't just
hit undo
on those things so very very good points
pays to be cautious all right so
to a few other things cognitive
enhancement or cognitive boosting
supplements
much like the testosterone playing field
there's a clown car full of ridiculous
propositions there are
of course then the prescription and
medical
route where there are certain things
that will help some things like nicotine
can be tremendously effective but come
with some possible downsides
associated do you have any particular
thoughts on cognitive enhancement or how
you
think about that specifically on the
pharmacological
supplement side i know there are many
other things that we could also talk
about
yeah i'm glad you mentioned it many
other things i won't list them out again
but i do believe that
the most powerful nootropic and
cognitive support is going to come from
quality sleep and yeah 100 agreed uh you
know so
it's night and day on the pharmacologic
side i
i think alpha gpc has
real effects that are supported by
quality peer-reviewed studies including
some
studies looking at offsetting
age-related cognitive decline
so generally it comes in capsule form of
300 milligrams or so
i think taken occasionally or more than
occasionally
provided it's fairly early in the day it
does increase focus without increasing
the kind of sympathetic arm of the
nervous system in other words without
increasing arousal
and alertness too much so i do think
alpha gpc is a useful
supplement and i use it from time to
time if i've slept well i don't take it
if i really want to push a workout hard
or a
work session a writing session or data
analysis session hard
i'll take 300 milligrams of that and
drink a couple espresso or drink some
mate
and some water stay hydrated hydration
is a big one for cognitive function and
it's one that people often overlook
but the simple rule is that this is what
i call the galpin equation because andy
galpin who's a great exercise
physiologist came up with this for
physical work but it turns out to work
for cognitive work too which is that
basically your body weight in pounds
divided by 30
will give you the number of ounces of
water that you should drink
about every 20 minutes when exercising
or doing mental work might seem like a
lot there might be an extra trip to the
bathroom or two
but it's worth it dehydration is a
subtle
but very pernicious creep where you
start having
a hard time focusing your eyes you you
just feel like you want to go to sleep
that hydration factor is real so drink
plenty of fluids especially if you're
ingesting caffeine which of course is a
diuretic
my personal favorite vehicle for
caffeine
remains yerba mate i just
absolutely adore the effects of yerba
mate i'm not saying it's for everyone
but you have the caffeine and i might be
getting the pronunciation off you also
have i believe
theophylline which you would find in in
green tea and theobromine
which you would also find and say dark
chocolate side note trivia for folks
bromine from theo as in theosophy
theobroma food of the gods so that's
kind of fun
yeah but the pharmacokinetics of those
are all different so
unlike coffee which i i have a love-hate
relationship
with because i metabolize it so quickly
that i get this
this sort of snickers bar sugar high of
caffeine for a very short time 20 or 30
minutes and then my baseline
of sort of subjective perceived energy
is lower than when i started so what
happens then i become a crackhead who
drinks you know eight cups of coffee a
day
not so with yerba mate especially when
you're kind of titrating it in in the
way that they would consume it in a
place like argentina or
uh uruguay where you're just kind of
sipping it slowly
it's great stuff i found a brand that
and i don't have any relation to them
but i found one that i particularly like
it's has a weird name but it's anna park
it's an organic and apart
i don't know who anna is or her park or
maybe her name is anna park but
it's nice it has the right amount of
that tobacco flavor but it's not
burnt to the point of feeling kind of
overwhelming
the other thing about caffeine that's
kind of interesting is that
most people would benefit from waiting
90 minutes to two hours after waking to
ingest their caffeine
the way caffeine interacts with the
adenosine receptor remember
you get sleepy because of time of day
with that
whole circadian clock mechanism but also
because of the buildup of adenosine
in your system that's the sleepiness
factor really
and when you wake up in the morning if
you immediately compete out
any residual adenosine you lose the
benefit of that cortisol pulse
essentially clearing out the rest of the
adenosine and
so a lot of people despite the pain of
having to do this the first day or two
feel much better throughout the day less
of that cracked out
kind of rise and crash feeling on
caffeine if they delay their coffee or
mate for about 90 minutes to two hours
after waking
oh that's great to know side note for
people who may want to do some
some further research and reading into
caffeine
the name roland griffiths has come up
multiple times on this podcast he's an
incredible scientist and researcher
based at johns hopkins who's
he is one of the most i would say
esteemed
researchers alongside say matt johnson
roland has just been
at it for longer with respect to
psilocybin
and psychedelic so he's associated with
that but prior to psychedelics
he was one of the world's foremost
experts in caffeine metabolism
and so he is he has published
and performed studies related to
caffeine that are
intensely interesting so for people who
want to dig deeper into that
roland is roland griffiths is a great
resource
you know one thing i've been wondering
because there are drugs
that you can use to counteract other
drugs right so if you go
to bellevue and you're at
the psych er and someone comes in just
high out of their mind on cocaine right
there are
medications they could be given to try
to take them down
a notch or two or three or ten like
halidol or
i'm not sure if that's used any longer
but there are many different
drugs that can be used in the case of
caffeine
let's just say someone named
jim barris just for sake of argument
is working on his laptop at a restaurant
and said restaurant
has excellent service which means they
also have the never-ending cup of coffee
and so before he knows it he's had five
cups of coffee even though he only
ordered one coffee
is there a way to reverse
or counteract the effects of caffeine on
adenosine such that you can actually get
to sleep so if you hit the golf ball
and you're like oh [ __ ]
looking at the half-life of caffeine
there's no way i'm getting to sleep
until like three in the morning
is there any way to address that or is
it just fade accompli and you're
more or less screwed yeah one direct and
two indirect the direct way to do that
is increase your glucose you know the
whole notion that you can soak it up
by eating some bread you will see a
blunting of the stimulant effect
now whether or not that's also due to
some i don't know increase in serotonin
or something from the carbohydrate
isn't clear but yeah you could have a
bagel or two or whatever it is that
you're the compatible carbohydrate these
days carbohydrates are such a
complicated thing for most people i like
carbohydrates especially late in the day
i do the i either fast and go low carb
no carb during the day because that lets
me focus
and that's a meat and salad during the
day are not eating for portions day and
then at night i eat pasta and rice and i
eat very little protein sleep like a
baby
that's what works but the other way is
to take
theanine so before we were talking about
theanine in reference to
pre-sleep supplementation 30 or 60
minutes before sleep
but a hundred to 200 milligrams of
theanine
will take the cheaters out of a caffeine
experience and in fact so much so that a
lot of energy drinks now are starting to
include
theanine as an attempt to get you to
ingest
more of those energy drinks because they
understand that at some point people hit
threshold and they feel so wide-eyed and
wired that they're not going to consume
more so they
they're tricking you this way and it
does indeed work the other thing is
if you ever really need to sleep i mean
again be cautious
do what's compatible with your
physician's advice but
gaba you know you can buy gabo and
glycine in capsule form
so a gram of gaba a gram of glycine in
combination
that's more of a heavy hit over the head
but if you're having a hard time getting
to sleep that can help i don't recommend
people take those chronically because
gab of course is a neurotransmitter
and i don't believe really in taking
things that are very close to the actual
thing that you're trying to manipulate
for instance i'm not a fan of
taking l-dopa why would i do that i
don't have parkinson's
but people take macuna purines which is
this
you know essentially 99 l dopa and
you'll get really really elevated but
then
you'll really crash for a day or two so
i think that
pulling on the marionette strings a
little bit from a distance
is better than taking the specific
compound that you're trying to replace
unless there's a clinical need of course
one more topic and since we're at about
two hours and thirty we'll we'll wrap up
in just a little bit but
the vagus nerve what is the vagus nerve
what is the latest and greatest why is
it of interest
yeah so the vagus nerve is a nerve
network it's many nerves
it could even be thought of as its own
major branch of the peripheral nervous
system it
comes out of the brain basically and
connects to all the organs of the body
and this is the pathway by which a
mental state can influence our digestion
our heart rate our breathing we talked
earlier about hrv heart rate variability
the vagus is an important component to
the slowing down of the heart rate when
we exhale
it's a very important pathway and it's
bidirectional so the organs of the body
that i just mentioned the lungs the gut
the heart etc the spleen
they also send nerve connections back to
the brain
and there's been a lot of interest in
the vagus as
a purely calming system and that's
simply not true
the medical textbooks call it
appropriately cranial nerve 10
it's in the parasympathetic arm of the
nervous system which suggests that it's
all calming but actually it's not it has
branches of it that are kind of
stimulating as well
so in the kind of wellness and self-help
community
you hear oh you know you should do this
thing of rubbing in front of your ears
that's a branch of the vegas that calms
you down or stimulate the vagus to calm
down now in
neuroscience laboratories and even in
some human neurosurgery laboratories the
way that you get people more alert
in fact a form of depression treatment
is to stimulate the vagus
and it makes people more alert and more
positive and excited
so vagal stimulation can easily cause
increases in alertness
how do they do the stimulation this is a
beautiful story a colleague of mine
perhaps at least to my mind the most
impressive neurobiologist i know a guy
by name carl deisseroth he
invented discovered and invented channel
rhodopsins which are these from algae
essentially
that are light sensitive clone the genes
you can put those genes into neurons you
have to do this by viral injection and
then you have a little
blue light diode that will allow you to
stimulate just those neurons locally
carl's a psychiatrist a bioengineer and
a neurobiologist
operating at the very highest level
actually there's a book that he just
published
that i'm listening to now that is it's
just can only be described as beautiful
it's a description of the landscape of
psychiatry and his attempts to build
tools that are better than drugs to
manipulate the nervous system it's
called
projections and it's a beautiful read
you'll learn a ton of neuroscience
carl is well on his way to win every big
prize in science he's got all of them
right now except
the last one and i'm not on the
committee that votes for those
but he's remarkable also has five
children happily married i mean he's
like one of these his wife is a
phenomenal scientist and physician these
people are
as one of the reasons i like being at
stanford is because the mean is so very
high but carl shifts the mean
like he's that dot way out there in any
event carl there's a beautiful article
that i can reference send you the link
to in the new yorker
where carl is sitting there talking with
his patient
and she has suicidal depression and
she's describing her
lack of desire to live and then he
cranks up
the intensity on this stimulation of the
vegas and in real time
she starts describing how she actually
would be interested in
applying for a couple of jobs this year
this is happening in the order of
seconds
by stimulation of the vagus what is the
machine what is it actually
uh how does it connect to her that one
is an implanted electrical stimulation
device that's placed
probably on there many branches of the
vegas and so on a branch that isn't
going to impact breathing right
sometimes people have challenges with
swallowing
so there are problems with doing that
carl a big part of his mission
is to create very small light diodes
that can stimulate nerves without the
need to inject viruses and things of
that sort
so that i think at the time not too far
from now
thanks to his work and the work of other
bioengineers we are going to be able to
stimulate for instance just the
serotonin neurons
in the raphe that lead to active coping
this is a well-known phenomenon
whereas when you take prozac or zoloft
or one of these other drugs it will
stimulate those neurons but will also
stimulate the serotonin receptors
on the spinal neurons that control the
sexual response and that's why they have
sexual side effects
so more precision is coming
so as it relates to vagus the other way
in which the vagus is stimulating
is something that we do quite often we
have neurons in our gut
that we all hear about the gut brain
axis and people say it's your second
brain but
very seldom does anyone actually
describe how the second brain actually
impacts the other brain
and the simple way to put this is we
have these neurons that live in the
mucosal lining of our gut
and those neurons sense three things
they sense fatty
acids so they like fat they sense amino
acids they love that umami flavor and
they love amino acids because that's
vital to protein repair metabolism etc
protein synthesis excuse me and they
like sugar and when you
eat something that has fatty acids amino
acids
or sugar these neurons send a signal
they're part of the vagus nerve up to a
little cluster of neurons in your neck
called the nodos ganglia n-o-d-o-s-e
and the nodo's ganglia then stimulates
your deep brain centers to release
dopamine
and the amazing thing about this these
are data from a guy named diego borges
at duke university
the amazing thing about this system is
that
even if you numb the mouth even if you
just gavage
a person or an animal and put these
substances into the stomach
you will seek more of these foods and so
you're actually seeking
sugar amino acids and fat
more when you ingest those foods
independent of how they taste and so
this has a whole set of implications for
hidden sugars and the fact that so many
of the foods we eat we just find
ourselves eating more of them we think
this doesn't even taste i don't even
know why i'm eating this it's because
these neurons in your gut are
stimulating dopamine release and as we
talked about before
dopamine isn't a molecule of pleasure
it's a molecule of making you want to do
whatever led to dopamine release
yeah the molecule of more the more
so the vegas is multifaceted and
we will soon hopefully subdivide it into
some more meaningful pathways
i don't like to knock on anyone else's
work but i do think that most of what
you read out there
about the vegas and what it does and
various theories about it are partial
truths to total nonsense
but they are partial truths to total
nonsense that were grounded in the
biology as we
understood it at the time and just a lot
more has been understood in the last
10 years or so so no disrespect to those
people but it's time for a revision
maybe two or three more questions then
we'll we'll go
get some food something along those
lines the first
is what books have you gifted the most
to other people or are there any books
that come to mind that you've
gifted often to other people
i love poetry and it's almost cliche now
to say this because so many people like
his work but i think david white's
work is just beautiful and is a
wonderful kind of entry point to
to poetry i'm also a big wendell berry
fan
has written a lot about farming and the
natural world and
i've never met him but i'm a huge
wendell berry fan some i'll sometimes
give
wendell berry books as gifts the book
that i
i think is perhaps at least to me the
most beautiful book of all
is longitude by dava sobel about the
history of
the discovery of time keeping at ocean
which is not a trivial problem to solve
and it's just a beautiful story of how
scientists or in this case a particular
scientist
merged the quest for a technology with a
scientific
problem with adventure and going out on
boats and
you know risking one's life for the sake
of science is something that resonates
with me a bit
it's a beautiful short book and it's
very accessible to anybody whether
or not you have a background in science
or not and she's an absolutely
wonderful writer and so that's the one i
gift most often
is there a particular david white book
or starting point that you might
recommend you know
i own several of his books but i confess
that i i'm
forgetting the titles now you know
what's interesting about david white
is that his poetry is best consumed by
listening to him
read it because he does this thing of
repeating things twice
and his cadence is so impressive and so
i would
even though i i loathe to kind of push
people toward online do buy his books
but uh i would suggest
just going online and listening to a
youtube video or watching a youtube
video of david
reading one of his poems he's on to
something the thing about poetry that's
so fascinating to me is the same reason
why i love
anything sung by bob dylan or joe
strummer
is that the words don't necessarily make
sense in the pure cognitive
landscape they're tapping into some sort
of deeper layer of the nervous system
that
defies the normal structure of sentences
and thoughts
and so i think they good poets are
accessing the subconscious
and has nothing to do with rhyming it
has to do with accessing some
layer of neurobiology that we just don't
have a name for
andrew this question is sometimes a
complete dead end and i'll take the
blame for that if it is but
just just to go fishing and see what we
catch here if you
could put anything on a gigantic
billboard
metaphorically speaking to get a message
out a quote
an image a word could be anything a
quote from someone else
anything at all to billions of people
what might you put
on that billboard well assuming this is
a big billboard i could probably squeeze
two things on there but i would diminish
the impact of either one so
it's so simple but it's the most use at
least has been the most useful thing in
life to me which is
credit goes to the oracle which is know
thyself
if there's one thing that's a really
useful pursuit
is to take a really good stock of what
you've come into the world with
and where you happen to be at present
get
really honest about that with yourself
and in doing that
it illuminates the path to filling in
the gaps and
improving oneself and knowing myself is
a dynamic process
and the answers to knowing thyself and
what that is will change over time but
that is the question that i think
everybody as soon as we are able to
should be asking ourselves and
constantly updating
know thyself what was second pick you
could put on the other side of the
billboard
yeah the other one was far weaker as the
um
one i think but use the body to control
the mind
i really worry about this current state
of the world where people are so unable
to regulate their autonomic nervous
system they're stressed they're angry
they're pissed
and look i suffer from this too
someone's sometimes a comment on
whatever i'm mostly on instagram but
sometimes on twitter and i notice
all this anger and stuff and you start
getting pulled into it from time to time
i regulate my behavior but i don't
respond but we're all subject to this
but
almost all harm almost
all self-harm and unfortunate things in
life are the consequence of a poorly
regulated autonomic nervous system we
say the wrong thing we
we do the wrong thing we're impulsive
etc and i think
controlling the autonomic nervous system
is simple
in one sense and challenging in the
other simple in the sense that the tools
exist
i do believe that respiration and vision
are are the two
ways to control the autonomic nervous
system in real time the best ones
and at the same time it's it's very hard
to do so we have to remind ourselves
that's why i'd want to put it on the
billboard
that when your mind isn't where you want
it to be
use your body to control your mind
i love that going to use that on a long
hike
with the pooch a little later today
and we'll also include for everybody
listening
show notes with links to various
resources
all the resources that we've discussed
so the yoga nidra
the various types of breath work
i'll also add a name which is lea lagos
dr lea lagos
has done a lot of really good work
looking at resonance training using
breath work
for improving hrv although improved hrv
is really just a proxy for all these
other desirable
outputs and effects in the world and in
life
so we'll include all of that in the show
notes andrew we've covered a lot of
ground
is there anything else that you would
like to
mention or say or point people to
any request of the audience anything at
all that you'd like to
add before we wrap up for today
we mentioned some of the things at the
beginning you know i teach neuroscience
on
instagram at huberman lab those are
resources brief snippets anywhere from
one to three minutes
about neuroscience exciting papers i see
a lot of tools
be wonderful if people want to check out
the podcast we cover a lot of topics not
just neuroscience and we batch those
by month so that we do four or five
episodes in one thing like hormones and
then move on to something else
and i suppose one request would be we
have the saying in a laboratory
it's certainly not unique to
laboratories which is watch one do one
teach one and what would be most
gratifying for me would be
if people find tools that they find
useful and they
that they learn about them that's the
watch one part that they do them they
apply them in their own life and
modify them if you like and then i think
the way the world works best at least in
my view is when people go on to teach
those tools and
attribution isn't required i didn't as i
always say you know i wasn't consulted
at the design phase
and i don't know anyone else that was
either so you know mother nature and
deserves and biology deserve credit for
all this and so
if people would like to learn practice
and teach
i like to think that the world can
improve by virtue of sharing of tools
i love it i dig it man and
there are a number of places people can
follow you and should check you out
as you mentioned the hubermann lab
podcast hubermannlab.com
and huberman lab huberman lab on
instagram
and twitter this has been so fun and i
really appreciate all the time
it's been a real pleasure spending time
with you andrew
and i look forward to many more
conversations i'm feeling that people
will want
a round two so until then thanks to you
and thanks to everyone for tuning in
hey guys this is tim again just a few
more things before you take off
number one this is five bullet friday
do you want to get a short email from me
would you enjoy getting a short email
from me every friday
that provides a little more soul of fun
before the weekend and
five bullet friday is a very short email
where i share the coolest things i've
found or that i've been pondering
over the week that could include
favorite new albums that i've discovered
it could include
gizmos and gadgets and all sorts of
weird [ __ ] that i've somehow dug up
in the the world of the esoteric as i do
it could include
favorite articles that i've read and
that i've shared with
my close friends for instance and it's
very short it's just
a little tiny bite of goodness before
you head off
for the weekend so if you want to
receive that check it out
just go to four hourworkweek.com that's
fourhourworkweek.com all spelled out and
just drop in
your email and you will get the very
next one and if you sign up
i hope you enjoy it this episode is
brought to you by
theragun i have two theraguns
and they're worth their weight and gold
i've been using them every single day
whether you're an elite athlete or just
a regular person trying to get through
your day
muscle pain and muscle tension are real
things that's why i use
the theragun i use it at night i use it
after workouts
it is a handheld percussive therapy
device that releases your deepest
muscle tension so for instance at night
i might use it on the bottom
of my feet it's helped me by plantar
fasciitis
i will have my girlfriend use it up and
down
the middle of my back and i'll use it on
her it's an easy way for us to actually
trade massages in effect and you can
think of it in fact
as massage reinvented on some level
helps with performance
helps with recovery helps with just
getting your back
to feel better before bed after you've
been sitting for way too many hours
i love this stuff and the all new gen 4
theragun
has a proprietary brushless motor that
is surprisingly quiet
it's easy to use and about as quiet as
an electric toothbrush
it's pretty astonishing you really have
to feel the theragun's
signature power amplitude and
effectiveness to believe it
it's one of my favorite gadgets in my
house at this point so
i encourage you to check it out try
theragun that's thera
t-h-e-r-a-g-u-n there's no substitute
for the gen 4 theragun
with an oled screen that's oled for
those wondering that's
organic light emitting diode screen
personalized theragun app
an incredible combination of quiet and
power so go to theragun.com
tim right now and get your gen 4th era
gun today or you can watch the videos
on the site which show you all sorts of
different ways to use it a lot of runner
friends of mine
use them on their it bands after long
runs there are a million ways to use it
and the gen fourth era guns
start at just 199 i said i have two
i have the prime and i also have the pro
which is like the super cadillac version
my girlfriend loves the
soft attachments on that so check it out
go to theragun.com
tim one more time theragun.com
tim this podcast episode is brought to
you by helix
sleep sleep is super important to me in
the last few years
i've come to conclude it is the end all
be off that all good things
good mood good performance good
everything seem to stem
from good sleep so i've tried a lot to
optimize it i've tried
pills and potions all sorts of different
mattresses
you name it and for the last few years
i've been sleeping on a helix
midnight luxe mattress i also have one
in the guest bedroom
and feedback from friends has always
been fantastic it's something that they
comment on
helix sleep has a quiz takes about two
minutes to complete that matches your
body type and sleep preferences to the
perfect mattress for you
with helix there's a specific mattress
for each and every
body that is your body also your taste
so let's say you sleep on your side
in like a super soft bed no problem or
if you're a back sleeper who likes a
mattress
that's as firm as a rock we've got a
mattress for youtube helix was selected
as the number one
best overall mattress pick of 2020 by gq
magazine
wired apartment therapy and many others
just go to helixsleep.com
tim take their two-minute sleep quiz and
they'll match you to a customized
mattress that will give you the best
sleep of your life they have a 10-year
warranty and you get to try it out for
100 nights risk-free they'll even pick
it up from you if you don't love it
and now my dear listeners helix is
offering up to 200
off of all mattress orders and two free
pillows
at helixsleep.com10
these are not cheap pillows either so
getting two for free
is an upgraded deal so that's up to 200
off and two free pillows at
helixsleep.com
tim that's helix h-e-l-i-x
sleep.com tim for up to 200
off so check it out one more time helix
h-e-l-i-x sleep dot com slash
[Applause]
time